Four three,
two,
one.
Hello?
Hello.
What's up buddy?
There's discrepancy.
My,
my coffee is way,
way bigger than yours.
I've got like this 40 ounce big gulp.
French press.
Yes.
Versus the,
is that a caveman cold brew?
Nitros yeah,
those are pretty good too.
It was called punch.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for the bread and the
Ma rooms and goodies.
That's awesome.
I would probably be morbidly obese if I
wasn't an exercise freak.
It seems like that.
Yeah.
Just so makes that sour dough bread and
it is freaking amazing.
Did you do that carnivore diet thing?
Did you try that out?
No.
You did.
No,
no.
I like me,
but I didn't do the cardboard that you
were going to do it for a certain amount
of time and test it.
Thought about it too much of a foodie.
I like,
what I did was I tried to eat Ribeye
steaks every night for dinner,
so I did like a 33% carnivore diet,
but there was a study actually that came
out.
It was just like two days ago on that
Tmao the the sugar that is associated
with gut damage when you're eating a
high red meat diet,
right.
When your body takes excess protein and
it turns it into sugar,
right.
With theoretically the idea of being
that that might be present because your
microbiome is imbalanced from a diet
that's too heavy and meat.
Is there a microfiber?
It's because you're buying them.
I thought it was just because of
glucogenesis because your body has
nothing but meet your body,
turns it into glucose.
No,
that,
that would be something different.
That that conversion of glucose is a
different sugar than the Tmao Tmao is,
is that's going to be present if you
aren't getting enough fiber or if you're
buying on his own balanced.
But what this study a couple of days
looked at was people who were eating
like a fish and egg and plant rich diet,
and they had high levels of Tmao too,
but they weren't deleterious there
actually as of tech because it had the
fiber.
Yeah,
and I mean you could do,
you could do a carnivore diet if you
were there.
There's a few populations that do this.
Like in Spain,
I forget the name of the sausage,
but they'll like eat the,
they'll eat the ruminant,
like delete the intestine of the
ruminant and get their grasses and their
fibers and their plants literally by
eating the stomach of the animal.
But like a cat.
Yeah.
And it's the same issue with like,
uh,
you know,
Mathias seen too much of the amino acid
methionine from just eating red meat
would be deleterious.
But if you're getting glycine and some
of these other amino acids,
if you're reading like nose to tail,
bone marrow,
bone broth,
all the organ meats,
you know,
head cheese,
braunschweiger just like all of these
different mixes of meats,
I think that would be the way to do a
car more diet.
Yeah.
This is a lot of people that are
proponents of that as well.
And then there's a bunch of people that
are,
you know,
it's interesting because you've got to,
there's a disparity between the
anecdotal accounts of health and
wellbeing and then blood work.
The blood work these folks get is not
impressive.
You mean the people on the cardboard?
Yeah.
What I've seen,
I haven't seen anything where I see all
their inflammatory markers down their
testosterone up.
I haven't seen anything where it's
looking really good.
High Blood Glucose is another thing that
you see what I should say that there
haven't been a lot of tests done.
It's not,
a lot of people are publishing stuff on
it,
but the anecdotal evidence is amazing.
It's like,
it's really weird.
Like,
uh,
my friend Jordan Peterson,
he's had a tremendous success with it,
lost a lot of body weight.
He says he's in his intellectual prime.
He said he's never felt better in terms
of his energy levels and that guy is,
he is so rigid and disciplined with it
all.
He's eating his meat with salt on it and
he drinks water and that is slowly,
well,
if you think about it,
it's an elimination diet,
right?
It's like an autoimmune diet or you can
say,
well,
you know,
I don't know what's giving me trouble.
Soy or wheat or dairy or what have you.
So I'm just going to stop eating all
that stuff and switched to primarily
meet.
The problem is that it's know I don't
want to call anybody out and,
and,
and call them lazy,
but it's almost like kind of a very easy
lazy esque approach because rather than
figuring out how to do that,
that sourdough bread,
it's slow fermented.
The Rye and the wheat are in there,
but all the phytic acid that would
normally inhibit your ability to absorb
minerals is pre digested by the lacto
bash list and all the bacteria in the
wheat.
So you've got a bread that's lower on
the glycemic index and it's,
it's more easily digested with some of
some of the dry and salad or more
health.
Right.
And you put the Ryan it because it
lowers the glycemic index and then
you've got the,
um,
uh,
what's it called?
The,
uh,
the,
I forget the term,
uh,
a,
it's like a gluten digesting enzyme that
gets activated with the lacto bachelor
lists.
So that's a smart bread.
I mean it takes fricken 24 hours to,
it's,
it's not 24 hours,
but it's like 15 minutes over 24 hours
that it takes to make it.
That's an intelligent approach to food
preparation,
right?
That's the way that our ancestors or
many of the blue zones would have
treated their foods fermenting,
soaking,
sprouting,
slow food,
and you can take a lot of these things
that would result in,
you know,
you're talking about Jordan Peterson,
I know his daughter does this as well,
and mckayla Peterson,
they use that elimination diet,
which is the carnivore diet to clear up
a lot of those autoimmune issues.
But you could also just render food more
digestible or switch to an elimination
diet or an autoimmune diet for eight
weeks or 12 weeks,
something like the Carnivore Diet,
heal the gut,
and then return back to a more all
inclusive eating pattern that allows you
to eat,
you know,
dairy,
wheat plants,
et cetera.
All these things that would normally
damage the gut
if the gut is actually
Wiki.
So what are the,
like what,
what's the process like?
What is happening when they go on this?
Very strict elimination diet and they're
just eating meat,
like what is happening to their gut that
allows him to have all these pretty
pretty significant health benefits.
A lot of loss of weight,
increase of energy,
autoimmune issues like Jordan had some,
um,
some pretty significant gum issues.
Those all went away.
Depression,
that went away,
right?
Some of that,
some of the gum in the joint stuff might
be just as much related to the fact that
he's getting a shit ton of college and
you know,
fiber eye or not fiber but odd elastin
and muscle fiber precursors.
He's getting a lot of protein.
I don't know if he's eating bone broth
and bone marrow,
but maybe a lot of glycine,
some of these other metabolites.
So part of it could just be more fuel on
board to repair muscles or to repair the
joints.
But then the other part of it is that
when you eliminate inflammatory products
that you're consuming,
like let's say you're eating whatever,
you know,
wonder bread and commercial dairy or,
or unfermented soy or any of these
things that can actually damage the
lining of the gut.
You're creating an inflammatory scenario
and I know you're,
you're familiar with the gut brain
access and how our gut interacts with
our nervous system via the vagus nerve
and when you have inflammation in the
gut that affects neural symptoms that
affect sleep,
it affects intellectual performance.
And then you've also got the autoimmune
component.
If you're actually truly allergic to or
intolerant to some of those proteins
that wind up in the bloodstream in the
presence of a leaky gut,
you know,
plant proteins,
uh,
lectins are another one that a lot of
people complain about.
Then you create almost like a full body
damaged scenario.
So the idea is you get rid of all that
stuff.
You introduced the carnivore diet and I
don't know that there's a lot of
components of the carnivore diet that
are actually healing the gut as much as
it's the absence or elimination of the
foods that were harming it.
Hmm.
Interesting.
The,
you know,
the,
the bell brothers,
Chris and mark,
do you know those guys?
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
their take on it is basically they've
never felt better.
And you know,
these are guys that work out very
heavily.
The difference between them and Jordan
is probably that especially if you know
mark is a gorilla,
he's power lifting and you know it has
been doing that basically his whole
life.
These guys are what their take on it is
essentially there.
At least the way they think is that most
people that are talking about diet,
they really don't know what the fuck
they're talking about.
Even though you might be able to look at
it on paper and you might have these
ideas about what's beneficial or non
beneficial.
Some people are proponents of Vegan
diets,
some people were proponents of you know
Paleo.
He's like until you are actually
physically doing something until you are
actually doing something with that diet
and then you report how much better you
feel that the people that are actually
training really hard,
those are the ones you should rely on.
And he's saying for him personally,
he's never felt better.
Never been leaner.
Yeah.
And a big part of it,
I mean this just returns to
personalization and customization as a
whole.
You know we live in an era where you can
self quantify pretty easily with
genetics and you can find out what
ancestry you came from,
what blood markers that you have,
what your gut microbiome looks like.
And I don't think we talked about this
on the last show,
but there's this idea of eating
according to your ancestry and the
concept of what are called cold spots.
Like areas around the world where people
have a genetic susceptibility to have
certain diseases that they don't
actually develop.
Those diseases don't actually manifest
because of their traditional diet.
Like you look at like the Icelandic
population that carries the genes that
would render them more susceptible to
something like depression or seasonal
effective disorder.
But their diet is very rich in omega
three fatty acids and Dha,
which we know can protect against those
disorders.
And then you take,
take the Icelandic population and you
uproot them and put them in the context
of a westernized diet and all of a
sudden depression and sad manifests.
That's interesting.
So the same thing for like a Cameroon,
Cameroon,
Africa,
higher than normal risk for colon
cancer,
but they're eating a diet that's high in
fiber.
Why is it higher than normal risk?
Well,
I don't know.
It's a genetic susceptibility,
but the idea is that that population
probably figured out at some point in
human history that if they eat a lot of
plants or they eat a lot of fiber,
all of a sudden people don't have as
many issues with their colon.
Right,
and then you take that same population
again,
strip out the fiber,
put them on a westernized diet,
and you get a large portion of the
African American population developing
colon cancer.
That's crazy about the seasonal
affective disorder and you've got to
wonder how would that affect people that
live in Seattle,
the Pacific northwest that are dealing
with constant rain.
I wonder if that would have some sort of
an impact on them.
Probably even more if you come from that
population.
I mean,
I'm on the spokane side,
but I'm out in the middle of the forest.
I get Sun for maybe 10 to two and I'm on
a north facing slope and I work in doors
a lot of the time.
You know,
I'm typing on my computer,
uh,
um,
blogging and so I don't get a lot of sun
exposure,
but that's where,
you know,
all these new fangled light panels and
head worn light devices and things come
in that were actually developed for
seasonal affective disorder,
that actually worked pretty well just to
keep your mood up if you're working in
doors and you'll get sunlight exposure.
Right.
But spokane has a different environment,
right?
You're not dealing with the constant
rain that they're dealing with on the
actual coast.
Now the precipitation builds up on the,
on the mountains and then dumps back on
in Seattle.
Yeah.
I mean it's still must be,
you must get much more than you get in
California or southern California at
least.
But,
uh,
it's,
it was supposed to be very beautiful out
there.
It's,
it's gorgeous.
So I'm about 25 minutes from coeur
d'alene.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's amazing.
I've never bought lines.
Beautiful.
I used to go over there and race the
ironman and they,
they'd have that in Lake quarter lane.
It's an iconic race just because,
I mean the mountains,
the lake,
everything is just gorgeous.
I saw pictures of the lake where people
were taking photographs of the bottom of
the leg,
like from a hundred a hundred feet deep
of water.
You could see the bottom of the lake and
stack.
Yeah.
That is insane.
It's kind of funny because it's actually
polluted because of all the mines of the
head around there.
Like there's a lot of metals in it.
Cause the quarter Lane Fijian,
the spokane river.
And you're at your allotment of fish
that you're supposed to eat from the
spokane rivers,
like one a year.
Why?
Like it's that high in metals.
So I mean,
I don't eat any,
I don't want,
I don't choose to go down there and
that's awful.
Yeah.
Dammit.
But it's a beautiful lake.
I mean it's,
what is the allotment of fish that
you're supposed to eat from the leg?
Because it's similar.
I don't know.
But if I,
if I went to quarterly and I spent a lot
of time swimming there,
I'd probably spend some time in the
infrared sauna to some of those metals
out.
So let me ask you this.
What's the benefit of infrared sauna
versus traditional sauna?
Is there a benefit?
So the,
the idea is it's cooler,
you know you have an infrared here?
No.
So you walk into the infrared,
it's like 155 258 degrees.
Most of them,
there's a couple of that'll go up to
like one 70 even though the air is
cooler,
the actual photons of light that are
being released by the panels,
you're,
you're surrounded by infrared panels
while you're in there.
Those penetrate more deeply into tissue.
So you wind up getting a deeper sweat.
You sweat for a longer time,
you can stay in there longer because
it's not quite as hot.
But you look at like the studies out of
Finland,
right?
These,
these studies that show four to five
year lifespan increases from a,
from a weekly sauna protocol of,
you know,
I think it's like four times a week for
20 to 30 minutes.
Uh,
and the,
and the significant drop in dementia and
Alzheimer's and a lot of these,
these mortality risk factors.
And you look at the studies that have
been done,
an athletes where you get almost a
[inaudible] and like,
like a blood doping effect from sauna
exposure when done postworkout right.
You stay in there for 20 to 30 minutes
workout.
All of these were done in a dry sauna.
That's why I use a dry sauna as per
Rhonda Patrick's recommendation.
I just got that cause she said there's
no real studies like that on an
infrared.
There's a few metal that,
so they,
they've analyzed metal and
detoxification and some of these
infrared saunas and they have found that
that you release more through your
sweat,
you get a deeper sweat.
So if your goal is something like
detoxification,
theoretically when I'm in that I'm
fucking drenched.
Like how could I get more out of that?
Have you tried like a like trial,
like a 30 minute infrared versus the
dry?
I have,
I,
I'm an idiot so uh,
I don't feel like I'm suffering as much
so I don't like it.
When you're in the infrared you don't
feel like yourself.
Exactly.
Yeah.
See that's the thing is,
and maybe I'm jaded because when I'm my
infrared,
like I've got a,
I've got a kettle bell in there.
I've put my bike in their yoga in there.
When I go in there at night,
it actually,
like I was telling you were talking
about those,
those massage devices,
those,
the sls,
the ones that are like a pso rit or like
a shift in your abs,
those things.
But they open up,
they open up.
You can work on a lot of body parts
anyway,
so I'll have stuff like that and there
and occasionally do bodywork,
but I actually move,
I exercise in the Sauna Sauna that's
designed for that.
What the fuck is that called again?
There's a specific sauna that a lot of a
UFC guys are using or in Vegas and
they're building them in gyms.
I know a winkle,
Johns,
Jim,
Mike.
It's kind of like a TV panel in there.
Yeah,
they have televisions in there.
So you can even watch things like watch
like a directionals or watch some sort
of a instructional video on exercise.
Yeah,
that's what I think they're doing is
they're trying to have you do your
workout.
Like you look at a screen and the sauna
and you do your workout while you're
looking at the screen.
It's on the spot.
I think it's called fit spa,
something like that.
But the,
um,
the,
the hot one that I go into mean I sweat
so much.
I have a hard time believing I would
sweat more anywhere else.
I mean,
I'm literally pouring sweat and I keep
that fucker around 190 degrees.
Yeah.
So I'm,
I'm really feeling ideal scenario.
I would like it.
I don't have a dry sauna,
but I would like to get a barrel sauna
because I have the infrared in my
basement.
It's one of those big ones,
like the foreperson,
infrared sauna and that you can get into
an exercise.
You can,
you can yoga more people in there.
You know,
do yoga,
whatnot,
and I'm,
you know,
I'm six two but I can get into like a
full down dog into a laundry or
whatever,
but I'd love to have a dry sauna as
well.
What is embarrassed on a barrel sauna
is,
it's like a big barrel.
You've probably seen them before.
They're,
um,
I don't think so.
They got benches on either side.
They're shaped like a,
like a cylinder.
Uh,
they're,
they're very popular.
They build up a lot of heat.
I think even the shape of the barrel
somehow allows the heat to be
distributed more evenly through the
sauna or something like that.
You know,
almost almost like a traeger grill,
for example.
Okay.
So this is,
uh,
yeah,
so that's like,
yeah.
So I've got,
what I did was I bought one of those,
um,
those endless pools that you swim
against.
Jamie,
go to that one in the upper right hand
corner with the bubble on the outside of
it.
That looks fucking awesome.
Yeah,
keep that sucker in your back yard.
I was at a guy's house in Santa Monica
at that thing and it heats up the same
way that some sort of a power source
attached to that.
Yeah,
that's pretty bad ass.
See I want to get one of those and just
put it out in the forest where I can
look out with the zoo or barrel song.
Yeah.
Looks fucking cool.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Especially if you were in like a cold
area and you could like,
like that,
look at that guys getting set up looking
over a leg.
You could look out into the snow.
Serene.
It's pretty like a pastoral scene in the
Cryo after you do the sauna.
I get sometimes.
Uh,
but most days,
no,
most days I do either or yesterday I did
cry.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I've,
I've been doing cryo everyday cause I'm
staying down at the Hilton and they have
a a crowd therapy chamber there.
Oh No.
I'm a bigger fan of the cold wave at the
Hilton.
Wasn't cryotherapy.
Yeah.
They've got a cryotherapy chamber.
They've got,
they've got a funny,
they have like this thing called upgrade
labs and like the basement of this,
uh,
this Hilton got like a Cryo,
they've got an infrared sauna,
they've got subject.
I've just been going down there every
day and working out my workout this
morning.
Actually I did this machine,
they've got a machine called a vasper.
Have you seen this before?
No.
You put like,
it's got cold cuffs.
You,
you know Kaatsu training,
like blood flow restriction training,
right?
So you put cold cuffs on your arms and
then you put cold cuffs on your legs and
it increased the millimeters of mercury
and tell you're basically get less blood
flow to your arms and your legs.
And then it's one of these full body
exercise devices,
right?
So you're moving your arms and your
legs,
like an elliptical trainer.
You're barefoot and the whole thing is
cold.
So it's pumping cold water through the
blood pressure cuffs on your arms and
your legs.
And then it's got cold water back behind
you on the areas right here watching
this.
Uh,
and by the way,
this,
this thing is not going to make you an
athlete.
Like that's not the purpose of a,
of something.
Like what is the purpose of it?
Just general fitness.
You know,
you're,
you're getting cold and when you take
off the blood pressure cuffs,
what happens is you've got a bunch of
lactic acid trapped in the muscle.
As you're,
as you're moving in,
typically you're doing like 30 seconds
as hard as you can go see Miko,
I mean pretty heavy wattage,
like 600 800 watts for 15 to 30 seconds
and then you recover and when you finish
and you take those cuffs off,
you get this amplification in growth
hormone,
testosterone.
And based on some of the research
they're talking about now,
stem cell mobilization.
So that,
and it's like this,
this super quick 21 minute workout.
I actually want to get one from my
house.
And how long has the amplification of
testosterone and growth hormone and all
that stuff?
I don't know.
I mean in many cases,
I mean it's like a lot of things that
affect testosterone or growth hormone or
inflammation.
Generally.
It's like a 24 to 48 hour cycle.
You know,
it's like weed,
you know,
we know that we'd suppresses
testosterone,
but it's not chronic.
It's a,
it's a temporary 24 hour drop in
testosterone.
Does it really suppressed his task does
know about that.
Yeah.
Although a lot,
a lot of the studies on on marijuana,
they're using pretty high dosage and
they're using rodent models using like a
hundred to 200 milligrams and road and
rushing.
Yeah,
and I'm sorry,
what would be the equivalent of a
hundred to 200 milligrams in a human on
a rodent model?
You know a lot of,
a lot of the studies on supplementation,
same thing with Tbi and concussion.
You know you hear about Dha and fish oil
for that,
but you need to take a lot of fish oil.
A lot of Dha,
like if you extrapolate from the rodent
models,
you're looking at like 50 to 60 grams of
Dha or fish oil to manage like Tbi or
concussion,
which is,
it's a lot of Dha.
But if you were going to use like a
multimodal approach to,
to Tbi or Alzheimer's or dementia,
I mean I'm a,
I'm a huge fan of that.
I'm a fan of,
of like hyperbaric oxygen therapy.
Um,
key ptosis definitely works that these,
these light devices that you wear on
your head now they've got a lot of
research coming out on something called
photo biomodulation for Tbi and these
things produce a hertz frequencies,
10 to 40 hertz range.
You place them on your head.
Typically there's like a probe that goes
into your nose and they've got new
research coming out on this for
restoring blood flow to the head,
increasing your Alpha brainwave
production or gamma grip brainwave
production.
Very cool devices.
Um,
so what does,
what does the probe up your nose do it,
it delivers a wavelength of light that
is supposed to activate.
Part of the Mitochondria is called
cytochrome c oxidase and when you
activate that you get increased
mitochondrial activity,
you get increased blood flow,
you get increased production of nitric
oxide.
And this kind of returns to what I was
talking about with seasonal affective
disorder where you can use a lot of a
lot of these new things that are
designed to deliver infrared light or
light to the body to increase
mitochondrial density or to increase
blood flow or increased nitric oxide and
people are not using this for Tbi and
concussion and then stem cells as well.
They've got a,
actually last time I was on the show,
we were talking about how when I got
that concussion in Austin,
I did a self administered fusion of
sugar alcohols.
I used man a tall and then I followed
that up with stem cells because at my
stem cells stored down in Florida and
also in this lab called forever labs in
Berkeley.
And I followed that up.
I chased it with a stem cell injection
because when you inject sugar alcohol
into your bloodstream,
it renders your blood brain barrier more
permeable and then the stem cells can
crossover through the blood brain
barrier.
But now hold on,
slow down.
So this show your how you,
what are you doing with the sugar
alcohol,
how you're administering it
intravenously and intravenous mannitol
solution.
You're doing this yourself.
I do this myself,
but you could get this done by a doctor
and when you're doing it elaborate,
I recommend you get it done.
But it sounds like a good idea to do now
what,
what kind of dosages are using of
Mannitol?
Yeah,
I don't remember what it was.
It was what I was advised to do by the
doc who,
who taught me this protocol,
remember how much it was.
But it was
like a vile.
Yeah,
I do.
I do the same thing with naed every week
I do a weekly Nad injection.
Everyone had said,
yeah,
push any,
say it takes you 10 minutes with Shy v
10 minutes is pushing it.
Um,
it hurt.
I mean,
so normally if you were to get 500 to a
thousand milligrams of Nad,
most people will sit under a four to a
six hour drip ivy to do that.
And one reason for that,
that,
that they say is that you get less of a
degraded by the liver and the kidneys
and the gut as [inaudible] goes into the
body then it put.
But I think,
uh,
I think that the bigger factor is simply
the fact that when you do a push,
like you're nauseous,
you feel like your whole body's on fire.
I mean if you feel like superman
afterwards,
but it's a very,
very uncomfortable ivy and I don't want
anybody pushing that and accept me.
Like I want to be in charge of the
trigger when I'm putting that thing in
because I got to stop and go and stop
and go.
But it's,
it's,
it's quicker.
It's more convenient than sitting down
and doing an ISV.
So a push,
you would actually have a nurse actually
pushing down on the button as things are
going.
Yeah,
exactly.
And it didn't intermittent intervals.
Uh,
I do about two like two ticks on the
syringe at a time cause it's a 30 ml
syringe.
So I'll go like two CC's then stop.
And you could feel like your heart rate
go up and you get nauseous and your skin
kind of flushes a little bit and you
breathe it off.
Then you wait like 10 15 seconds and you
do another push.
Kyle Kingsbury was saying it felt like
his guts were on fire.
Yeah,
caught kyle I think is a champ.
I think he did it in like five minutes
or something,
but it sounds like for me,
if I,
if I can do it in 10 minutes then it's,
it's absolutely mind blowing in terms of
how hard that is.
I don't know how he did it in five
minutes,
but,
well he's a savage.
You know it's interesting.
I started to listen to your podcast with
David Sinclair on the,
on the car ride over and he's talking
about this nmn stuff,
which supposedly when orally
administered simulates a lot of what an
ar,
nicotinamide riboside,
which is one thing that a lot of people
are taking for anti aging and in a d,
which is what we were just talking
about,
administered via either,
in most cases it's ivy,
there's a couple companies doing like an
oral and a d version,
but supposedly,
man,
an mn,
uh,
I don't know if sinclair has any human
studies coming out on this right now,
but he or,
or at least released,
but he's done in the studies and show
that it's like exercise in a bottle.
The Nad,
from what I understand though,
and this returns to the Tbi concussion
piece crosses the blood brain barrier
easily or more easily than nmn or nr.
So if you were doing it for like a
cognitive or neurological effect,
you may want to choose Nad.
It sounds to me like from the research
I've seen,
if you were doing it for the exercise
effect,
maybe you choose nmn or nr.
Interesting being anti aging effect.
I mean they don't even know in many
cases ha all the pathways on which these
things are working.
But most of them are related to these
sirtuin pathways where it likes or two
inactivating compounds that actually
allow your mitochondria to repair more
quickly or give your body more
antioxidants.
So the idea is they probably all have a
pretty good effect on anti aging.
And when you're doing it,
are you pushing yourself?
You said you're doing it once a week or
you did it yourself,
but you pushing it.
Yeah.
And how much time do you give yourself
to actually do the nmd?
Yeah,
if I've got 20 minutes,
I'm happy.
If I have to compress in a 10 minutes it
at hearts like I like to at least allow
for 20 minutes.
And then,
uh,
you follow it up in most cases with like
an ivy cocktail,
like a,
like a myers cocktail vitamin cocktail
and supposedly supposedly that it does a
few things.
Supposedly it enhances your stem cell
mobilization or the or the activity of
stem cells and allows the n d to be
absorbed into the cells more easily.
So you basically,
I mean the way I do it is I use it like
it just a butterfly needle and you do
the Nad administration and then you just
unscrew the,
the end of the,
the butterfly needle line.
And then you put the vitamin cocktail
and follow up with vitamin cocktail,
which takes like 30 to 60 seconds and
then you're done.
And why do you do it once a week?
Did you feel good?
No.
But why,
why once a week?
Why not twice a week?
Why?
The idea is you're,
you're supposed to maintain your levels
and there's even some evidence and,
and it,
you know,
this is kind of similar to testosterone,
that longterm use may suppress your
body's on nad production.
So we're going to start to do it.
Great.
But you may want to realize that this is
something you'd need to do regularly and
like to keep your levels elevated
because you may get like a
downregulation of fact.
Oh,
interesting.
So your body might recognize that it
hasn't up a surplus.
It's got a lot of Nad.
It doesn't need to make more.
One of the,
uh,
one of the very interesting things
though I did a couple of weeks ago was I
went to New York City and I got Nad from
this doctor,
a Dr. Chen over there.
But then he infused me with a co q 10
and a bunch of other vitamins to allow
my body to make more of what are called
adult pluripotent stem cells.
They're also known as the t cells,
very small embryonic like cells.
Now if you've heard of a pair of biosis
before this idea of taking the blood
from young mice and transferring that
into old mines,
there was research that they did at
Stanford University on this.
You impart essentially enhance longevity
to the old mice.
The idea is that's a,
that's a non autologous transfer or I
like that.
So that's the transfer of blood from a,
from my young healthy donor into an
older recipient.
And there are companies now in silicon
valley doing this,
like the young blood institute,
you know,
for like $8,000 this company called
Ambrosia.
We'll,
we'll give you the plasma from a young
healthy donor.
Is there any evidence that that does
anything good for you though,
other than the studies that they've done
in mice?
Uh,
I don't know of any studies on humans.
Yeah,
no,
it was their anecdotal evidence.
I mean,
if people that,
you know,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm about to,
to get into that.
But you haven't,
no,
I did an autologous version of that,
so I didn't want to put somebody else's
blood so he didn't run body.
So what I did was I had this doc take
out a pint in my blood.
And what happens is if you've put all
these vitamins like Nad and stuff into
your blood,
it increases your stem cell production.
If you stress the blood after that,
it dumps out a bunch of these tiny
little adult pluripotent stem cells,
which is exactly the same type of cell
that you're getting when you do one of
these young blood transfers.
So he stresses that overnight in cold
you can use cold,
you could use pressure,
you could use anything to,
to increase the stem cell release from
the blood cells,
but they get stressed out.
They released stem cells and then what
happens is you get them injected back
into your body.
So this is similar to like what they're
doing with Regena cane.
I don't think it's anything like that,
but you know Janky and they take the
blood out and they stress it with hia
and then they spin it in a centered
view.
But I think,
I think,
and I don't know a lot about what regena
keen is doing,
but I think they're more concentrating
the growth factors.
I think they might be doing exosomes.
I know they've got some overseas places
where they're doing like a culture
expanded or something like that.
But as far as in the u s like this,
this protocol is one of the few that I
know of where you could take your own
blood and get a lot of that same stuff
that you'd get from culture expanded or
from para biosis,
like using the blood of somebody else
and you get all these stem cells
released into your body.
So you essentially get the same effect
as you would if you took young person
who if he did a young blood transfer and
the young blood transfer,
then not transferring the entire bodies
supply of blow their third month,
they're taking the,
taking a bunch of plasma,
I dunno,
the volume that they're using.
In my case they took a pint of my blood.
So four,
four 60 cc tubes.
Now is there any anecdotal evidence or
any published evidence on your style,
the what you're trying to do and the
benefits of it?
No.
Ms. Dot equals one.
I just felt like 1 million bucks
afterwards.
The,
um,
the other one that I did that worked for
a while,
my knee,
because I have some meniscus issues on
my left knee was I did what's called a
nerve hydrodissection.
Have you heard of this before?
I'll,
hydro dissection is a protocol where
they take a,
like a liquid and they used the liquid
to act like the scalp or the knife that
a surgeon would use to kind of remove
adhesions like scar tissue adhesions or
separate a nerve that's causing pain or
discomfort or lack of mobility in a
certain joint.
But when they do a nerve hydrodissection
they don't have to use like,
you know,
something like they'd use in
prolotherapy like sugar water or regular
water.
Uh,
what I had done,
and this was at a clinic called bio
reset in uh,
in San Jose with Doctor Matt Cook down
there.
He went in and did a nerve
hydrodissection and he used ozone and a,
a placental cell.
And it wasn't like a culture expanded
placental cell,
which is what I understand to be illegal
in the u s but just like a regular
placental extract.
He did that into my knee and my knee
went from like 25% to 100% in a couple
of weeks.
And that that protocol was called nerve
hydrodissection.
They use ultrasound imaging to,
to basically visualize where the needle
is going into the knee.
They identify the area where the
adhesion or the scar tissue is.
They inject it right there and then the,
I mean it's like a 10 minute long
procedure.
Now this is for only a buildup of
adhesions and scar tissue.
What about for people that,
you know Mike,
it was coping.
Yeah,
it was developed for nerve pain and what
they found was that it actually seems to
cause some kind of a release of the scar
tissue followed by an increase in the
blood flow,
which is difficult to get in some areas
of the knee especially.
So yeah,
I mean I will,
if I ever get to the point where
somebody wants to sculpt my knee or
something like that,
I would,
I would definitely consider doing that
dream of first cause they worked very
well and it was just quick and easy.
I had a meniscus issue and I got
exosomes shot into that.
I've had it done three times
now and every time I've done it I've
experienced a good benefit from it.
But then I beat the shit out of it and I
think I gave it not enough time to heal
up before I started pounding again.
I would give it like a week off,
then start running again.
But now I'm going to give it a full six
weeks with a no pounding,
no running hills,
nothing crazy.
And I've experienced just in the two
weeks since the procedure,
a very significant decrease in pain,
no inflammation,
decreasing.
Discovered.
I have to like try to make it feel weird
now I have to like go out of my way and
it seems like every week that's more and
more difficult to do and range of
motions increased.
Uh,
basically it can go all the way down
with my ass to my ankles,
no problem,
you know,
and bend all the way down and back all
the way up with no discomfort,
no weirdness.
Yeah,
I kind of question the one thing,
cause I've asked myself this before and
I don't know if you have,
like when you get a protocol like that
done any kind of go easy on your knee
because you really want it to work and
you start backing off as some of that
stuff you were doing anyways.
How much of it is you just backing off
of what you were doing and how much of
it is the exosomes and the south cells?
I know because I did try to back off
initially and it didn't have any
incident compared.
Yeah.
When I,
when I backed off initially with
nothing,
I said let me just take some time off
and let it see if I can let it heal up.
Didn't,
it ain't shit.
It just,
it stayed exactly the same.
Like it was just hurt,
you know,
like,
so it was one of those things where in
the past I would have had to just deal
with it.
Now this is my new world,
this is my new feeling and my knee until
I get it scoped.
Yeah.
So it's pretty significant.
The impact that it's had.
I mean,
I'm a giant believer in stem cells and
exosomes.
I had a full length rotator cuff tear in
my right shoulder and now it's gone.
It's gone.
Like it doesn't exist anymore.
And Doctor Rodney Mcgee out a vegas
coat.
You know what?
He looked at the,
uh,
the MRI and he said to me,
he goes,
do you know how fucking crazy that is?
Like you had a tear and your rotator
cuff and now there is no tear.
Like it's regenerated tissue.
It's crazy.
She's the ultimate goal,
right?
I mean,
now I have zero pain in this shoulder.
nothing did you do,
I was like,
did you not have belong?
I did peptides.
I did a,
what does it bpc one,
five,
seven.
Yeah,
that will be the pc one five,
seven.
That's the only one that's,
that's still legal according to Usada
and Wada for athletes to use.
And that one decreases inflammation and
increases blood flow.
And then the other one,
the one that that's not allowed anymore
as tb 500 times and Beta 500 and not one
repairs.
The Actin and myocin fibers.
And so in a,
in a gold standard protocol,
you go back and forth between the two.
When you switch it up one one day,
like inject subcutaneously near the site
of injury now works for a lot of people.
The peptides are weird.
Like I'm,
I'm attending all these anti aging and
longevity conferences now cause I want
to learn a lot more about this.
I'm almost Kinda,
I'm kinda starting to pivot from just
pure human performance to how
can you,
how can you live a long time and talk to
sinclair.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well I want to finish listening to your
interview with him cause I was intrigued
by have an older guy.
Yeah.
So the,
um,
the idea is that these peptides are
talked about a lot now in these anti
aging circles.
Like they,
they've got weird names like,
like epic Taylon is one and two times a
year,
like a 10 to 20 day injection protocol
of epic Taylon.
They're getting a bunch of increased
mitochondrial density,
decrease markers of aging,
uh,
increased fat loss,
increased muscle gain.
And they've done that in humans.
And so again,
it's just a peptide.
It's very easy.
Like you,
you would inject it next to your
abdominals subcutaneously.
There's another one.
No side effects.
This one,
uh,
not with that one,
but this one called Melanotan.
Have you heard of it before?
No.
So I was intrigued by this.
Somebody was telling me about it.
It's a,
it's a peptide and it was used in the
bodybuilding industry for a long time
because when you inject it,
it gives you,
uh,
like this amazing Tan and they call it
Malano.
Tanis stimulates your Melanin lady that
was on that fucking show that was
turning black.
She believed that she was,
yeah.
Then the wrong skin.
So she was shooting something into her
body and she got black,
like Congo black.
Well,
I,
I tried it out.
I tried it out for about a week.
You try to get black?
No,
I didn't try to get black.
I just want it.
Just wanted to see what happened to the
Tan.
And I started to get some freckles.
But the side effect of this is you get
massive boners that lasts a really
annoyingly long time.
So you were like,
you can't say no,
but people will use this is like almost
light,
like an ed type of drug,
but it,
and I don't even know the mechanism of
action.
Like I don't know how it's even working.
Well,
it's giving you a black,
so basically you get it.
Yeah.
You get a Tan and boners.
Yeah,
this is all,
yeah.
I don't know.
That's not how you would administer
Malana.
She's,
she's doing some kind of like a volume.
What is that thing that she's doing with
the syringe?
What?
That looks like a caulking gun.
Like what is she doing?
Picture,
I don't know.
Yeah,
that bitch isn't as a type of thing like
the Kardashians are doing to their ass
cheeks,
like fillers.
I don't know what they're doing.
They're doing something that seems like,
well,
it's very popular with the young people
these days.
They're taking fat out of certain parts
of their body and putting it in their
ass.
Right.
It's not,
I don't,
let's,
we should find out.
That's how I see getting diaper,
but just google are women today.
How are instagram models getting diaper?
But I'm curious because that's what it
is.
It's what you're using their own.
Taking their fat from somewhere else on
their body.
Yes.
Injecting.
I know that some people do that.
We should do that for our calves.
That way we could start an instagram
calf channel.
No,
I don't want fat calves where the
Jiggling and walk like a girl's butt
while he's pulling that up.
What kind of coffee is this?
Uh,
this is black rifle coffee.
It's good.
Yeah,
it's good stuff.
Yeah.
I,
I figured out something.
Uh,
thank you by the way,
for hooking me up with trigger.
Oh Great.
Let's try your timber lines.
Those are the Shit I've been making a
coffee rub for the coffee rubbed before.
Yes,
I have trigger.
Has their own coffee rub you?
Well,
they have their own,
I love you trigger,
but I sometimes never know what all is
in some of these spices and rubs.
You know the lab sometimes Maltodextrin,
sugar and stuff.
There's some sugar in there.
So I find grind,
I find grind coffee and I mixed that
with Black Kona,
salt,
Cayenne pepper and Paprika.
And you can just make that rub his stick
as you want.
Put that on the Ribeye.
And I've almost switched completely from
doing my,
my stove top sear followed by the quick
broil on either side to doing like a one
and a half to two hours smoke in the
trigger with that coffee rub on and
they're just finishing it on the grill
with the tracker.
Yeah,
I did a uh,
uh,
what,
what would you call it?
A prime rib,
you know,
like,
so instead it's basically ribeye roast
and I did one on the trigger and I
cooked it for like four hours at 220
degrees.
Holy Shit.
You smoked it for hours?
Yes,
yes.
And that it had,
I use the traders
smoke at that temperature.
This is a super smoke setting at two 25
and below.
Okay.
Press the super smoke button and it
constantly infuses this pump of smoke
like,
like it's like,
Whoa,
I've never tried super smoke at that
high of a temperature.
Good loans or US delicious dude and the
but the trager prime rib rub.
I know it has sugar in it.
It's tastes too delicious to not,
but holy shit when it's in there for
three and a half,
four hours and it has that crossed on
it.
There's some words some about that long
smoke.
Have you tried to beer?
Can chicken beer can chicken?
So I've,
I've tried a bunch of different rubs on
that but just,
just core salt and black pepper works
fine for the beer can chicken you empty
about half of the beer can out.
You open up the beer can but then you
poke a couple extra holes in the top so
you get more of the steam so they inside
of the chicken gets even more moist.
But then when I figured out is if you
use like a little little scalpel or
exacto knife and you cut open the skin
of the chicken around the outside a
little bit and you stuff that with pads
of butter and then you do your smoke
pads of butter and said the chicken that
the skin gets crispy,
super crispy and so you just,
it's like,
I think it's like an hour,
an hour and a half.
He Cook that one and he can't,
you can't smoke that one very
successfully.
Like you want to run the grill with a
smoke on but you can't super smoke it
and didn't seem to work so well,
but that beer can chicken.
That's frickin amazing.
Whoever figured that out,
whatever drunk figured that out as a god
damn genius.
It works.
But I've wondered before if there are
other things that will work even better
than beer.
We've got Jamie,
it says in most cases what I'm finding
is either Brazilian butt lift or just
like a fat graft or fat injection.
But there have been cases where I'm
seeing that they had to get an injection
taken out within weeks because it was
causing a problem.
So like I don't know if that was just
fat.
Do you got the fat put in then you have
to get it,
take it back out.
Yeah.
Cause they were to,
they were dying the bar.
Great.
And then you have this fucking war zone
of an hour.
Yeah.
Most of it is light leaves,
some bars.
Syrian few pocs.
Airstrip.
Yeah.
No more.
G string,
32 people died supposedly in 2017 from
wonderful.
Yeah.
That's like the same amount of people
that died from coconuts fall on their
head.
That's a fucking ridiculous way to die.
You know?
And here's the thing,
the,
what they're doing is not aesthetically
pleasing because it violates your
sensibilities cause you look at the ass.
Then you look at the legs and you go,
what's wrong here?
How did you get that ass with those
legs?
They don't go together.
Like if you look at like a crossfitters
legs,
like one of them powerful gals with a
big butt,
but they also have to shoot with those
eyes.
The high neon compression socks.
Ooh,
la La.
It looks right.
It fits.
Like if the assets,
it's the thigh,
it's not entirely disproportionate.
Yes.
When the ass pumps out and then it goes
to a little toothpick legs,
you're like,
that's gross.
That's weird.
You know,
like it's comical.
That's a real ass.
Graham.
We may be evolving as a species to find
these type of things more attractive
though,
because that's the whole idea was social
media is you get a dopamine hit every
time you click on the little blue
notification button or you look at a new
photo.
So maybe we're just going to eventually
develop a real appreciation for that
type of symmetry.
No,
we'll redefine.
All right.
Know what true human symmetry is
incorrect.
It doesn't look as good.
It just doesn't look as good.
It's a,
it's a cheap fix your squats.
Yeah.
Get your ass to the gym.
Girls to sit down wefts run up hill.
Uh,
alright.
So squats and muscle building.
Uh,
did you see that Rhonda?
Patrick tweeted that study about mice
and Mile Nuclei and how when they,
when they dope mice they actually,
they never actually lose the muscles.
Mile Nuclei.
Yeah.
It's like those don't actually ever
disappear even just when you dope but
just when you lift period muscle milk
essentially we had already known bill
down muscle memory.
Muscle memory is always been in sort of
an anecdotal idea.
We'll muscle memory has been in many
cases just based on a motor unit
recruitment like meaning like you know,
like my wife,
she ran for University of Idaho and when
I go out running with her still,
even though she doesn't train,
she's just got faster leg turnover,
she's got better form.
Like her body just remembers that.
The same thing with a swimmer,
right.
I'll,
I'll do a triathlon.
Somebody who swam in college but hasn't
swam in 10 years will kick my ass just
because they have that muscle memory in
terms of which,
which motor units to recruit when.
But this latest one was basically the
idea that you retain actual Myo Nuclei
in the muscle.
Like they thought for a long time that
those just disappeared and went away
once you detrained.
But it turns out that they're all still
there.
So as soon as you start training again,
you build muscle more quickly.
And furthermore,
and that,
and this was kind of like the political
part of it is if you've done some kind
of,
you know,
illegal performance enhancing procedure
or steroids or adult or whatever,
you actually would have a higher
concentration of micro nuclei or mio
nuclei available.
And there,
there was a study even leading up to
that,
and this was,
I think this was like 2013 like this was
a while ago where they took mice and
they gave one group testosterone.
The other group didn't get it and then
they spent six months off testosterone.
I don't remember how long they were on
it,
but they spent six months off it.
And then they took those mice and they
trained them with the training protocol
and the mice that were on the
testosterone.
But we're no longer on,
it had a 30% increase in muscle mass
compared to the other mice that only had
a 5% increase on it.
So once again,
the,
and this was probably related to that,
my nuclei thing that just came out in
this recent study,
so it turns out that a,
you should,
you should lift like when you're young
because you can build all these micro
nuclei that just basically hang around
your body and then b,
when they like ban somebody from sport
for doping and then they come back and
start to compete in that sport again,
they still have an advantage.
Mm.
Well that that has huge implications for
MMA is this,
that's the big debate right now.
How long should someone get suspended
for and for how long,
you know,
how long afterwards should they be
considered enhanced?
Yeah.
You know,
like they're giving people some pretty
significant suspensions now for
steroids,
like two years.
But you know,
there's this Jon Jones case and I'm sure
you're aware of,
do you wear this?
Yeah.
Where he's testing positive for the
metabolite,
for the longterm metabolite,
for a very small dose.
He's never tested positive for short
term metabolite.
Which testosterone?
No,
it's not testosterone.
It's um,
what is the stuff?
Terrana ball.
Yeah.
And essentially it's a tainted
supplement and it's not,
it doesn't have any performance
enhancing benefit in terms of like the,
the,
the amount of the dosage that he's
tested positive for,
but it's lingering in his system because
the protocols for,
um,
the weather ability rather to detect
these metabolites has increased rapidly.
And over the last year it's just
unbelievably more sensitive to the point
where,
you know,
they're detecting these infants
reasonably small levels of these
metabolites.
And there's also seems to be some sort
of a pulsing effect when your body
releases these infant testimony,
small metabolites and then doesn't,
so you'll test negative and then the
next week you'll test positive,
but only for the longterm metabolite,
which is an indication that there's no
re administration of the performance
enhancing drug.
Yeah.
So it's real,
it's in everybody's mad.
There's so many athletes that are mad
about it.
And from what you're saying and for this
study that Doctor Rhonda Patrick
highlighted,
it's,
you know,
it's especially for someone who's
willingly taken something
dope are always a doper type of things.
There is that.
But see the John Jones situation is very
tricky because she's so good and he's so
dominant that people just assume that
he's been doing something his whole
career.
You know?
And when you catch them they're like,
Aha.
That's the reason why he's so good.
And it may be,
but it also might be,
he's got phenomenal genetics.
He has two brothers.
He was just the,
the best of the guys who are taking
drugs.
That's a different situation because
that's a sport where at least in the
time period where he was competing,
everyone was doing something.
Yeah,
100% they had to go meet.
All the UFC is like that.
It's not right that it's not,
it's not.
It can't be.
They're too strict.
The Usada is knocking on doors at six
o'clock in the morning,
pee in this cup,
and you,
you do hear about positive tests,
but the amount of positive Taz versus
the negative test is overwhelming way
more guys are not doing something.
It used to be the opposite.
It used to be in the nineties everyone
was doing something.
We were just talking about this on the
fight companion podcast that a big issue
is grappling.
Grappling competitions are overrun with
steroid users because no one's testing
and these,
I mean it's the smell test is off the
fucking charts.
You're looking at these guys who just
ridiculous,
just jacked,
low body fat,
super high muscle mass and their
training Jujitsu all the time too.
So you would think it would be very hard
for them to maintain muscle mass as well
as be able to train the way they're
training with technique and drills and
cardio and it's very difficult to
maintain muscle.
Any,
any concurrent strength endurance
training scenario.
Very difficult,
very difficult.
So there's a real issue with some of
these guys competing this way and then
trying to transition into MMA now.
What,
what's the deal with marijuana in
[inaudible] in mma?
Pretty much legal now.
Um,
the,
they don't in season,
out of season.
Yeah,
it's fine.
They just,
they've lowered the um,
acceptable level or the they've raised
it rather like what you could have in
your bloodstream.
You basically just can't be high the day
of the fight.
Yeah.
And that's another interesting one.
I mean that acts,
especially thc acts on a lot of these
mtor pathways,
you know,
that's,
that's the same thing with a lot of
these anti aging compounds,
right?
Like wrap a myosin or met form and to a
lesser extent acts on that end tor
pathway and inhibited.
Right.
But again,
it's,
it's short term was something like
marijuana and you also get this pain
killing effect.
And there was,
I forget if this was a study or if it
was,
if it was like anecdotal,
but it's almost like a higher thrill
seeking effect.
Like the endocannabinoid system when
stimulated shuts down some of your,
your,
your sense of fear when it comes to
experiencing a new adventure.
Really.
And so you actually,
you actually go adventure seeking more.
And when you look at like ultra runners,
um,
anybody who's competing in a,
a non,
a complex activity in which they might
have already developed the ability to be
able to be in the zone,
right?
They've put in their 10,000 hours of
practice and they're able to just kind
of check out and go into automatic mode.
When you combine that with the pain
quelling effects of something like,
uh,
you know,
in most cases like a thc cbd Combo is
what a lot of ultra runners are using.
I'm not sure what what they'd use in,
in mma right now,
but ultimately you get a good effect.
But,
but the loss of reaction time and the
loss of the ability to be able to
perform complex tasks,
which they proven like flight simulation
studies dictates that it's still not
that great of a drug if you are going to
be doing complex tasks.
The question though,
when they're talking about reaction
studies done,
they talking about reactions,
studies for people that are acclimated
to taking marijuana or they talking
about it with people where they take a,
someone who's a sober person and they
introduced him to marijuana and there's
this overwhelming effect of it because
one of the things that happens to people
that aren't accustomed to thc is the
freak out effect where they're just
like,
they're not comfortable with the
experience.
After a while,
the way it's described,
and again,
this is all anecdotal,
but by people that are accustomed to it,
they say,
you just get good at being high and see
the reaction time thing.
I don't buy because a lot of strikers,
a lot of uh,
kickboxers they train what while they're
on marijuana,
it's very common.
A lot of leave it on reaction time was
done on pilots and there's a,
there's a few more blinky lights in a
cockpit than,
than a mat.
So sure that my more going on.
Sure.
But that's the,
the question is,
are they experienced stoners or these
people that are freaking out and maybe
the reaction time is they're spacing out
and they don't know what the fuck this
experience is like.
And there they might have anxiety
because of it.
You know,
there's a lot of uh,
really overwhelming sensations that come
with that marijuana high.
And a lot of them,
you know,
you call it paranoia or over sensitivity
and sometimes you get paralysis by
analysis when you're under the influence
of those things where it's the acute
versus chronic effect.
But Jujitsu,
personally,
my personal experience with Jujitsu and
marijuana is,
it's an enhancer and I've argued this,
that I think it's a performance
enhancing with cbd.
CBD.
No,
just marijuana.
That's what,
that's what a lot of endurance athletes
are.
You know,
like,
like folks in the ultra running
communities and now like they'll use
like a trace amount of thc combined with
cbd,
like four to one to attend to one cbd to
thc ratio.
And I think you know now with the farm
bill and increasingly gallery,
I think this idea of developing sports
performance supplements for athletes,
you know who aren't competing in sports
that is band are going to be steered in
the direction of like high cbd and then
some of these other novel molecules,
right?
Like CBG or CBN.
I'm not aware of this.
What are those?
Yeah,
there's,
there's all these different terpenes.
Yes,
CBN
or cannabinoids.
THC eight is an antiinflammatory that's
totally different than thc nine ladies
from orally ingesting it or from smoking
it or they actually are an owl isolating
these in labs almost like organic
chemistry and you,
you,
you can take hemp or marijuana and you
can actually isolate specific compounds
and then combine them.
So you could take,
like you could take like CBG CBD,
combine that with other turpines from
like whatever.
Let's say lavender and Valerian and
camomile and make like a,
like a de stress relaxation type of
compounds.
Or You could do like a,
like a thc but a thc eight instead of a
thc nine and combine that with like
cinnamon and peppermint,
maybe some caffeine or creatine or
something like that to make like more of
a pick me up type of compound.
But I think that's,
that's the wave of the future when it
comes to a lot of these,
these marijuana companies that are
developing stuff for specific goals.
I know a lot of folks that are trying to
cbd that use it for information,
especially athletes like it with a
little bit of Thc,
they seem to think it's more effective.
You know,
there's some sort of a combined effect
of the thc with the CVD.
Yeah.
They call that the a,
the entourage effect,
you know,
when you have all the different terpenes
and the endocannabinoid,
which one's turtle?
Yeah.
Which one's turtle have no clue.
So,
um,
there's hundreds of different,
different cannabinoids,
right?
I don't think there's hundreds.
Well,
I think there's at least dozens.
I don't know about hundreds.
How many of them,
I mean if,
if you,
if you look at a chart of the different
Endo cannabinoids,
they've actually discovered if you were
to just google 113 yeah.
So it's a lot.
It's a lot of fucking cannabinoids.
I wonder.
Yeah,
I wonder if there'll be able to like
design something that gives you the high
without the paranoia or gives you the,
you know,
various effects without spacing out.
Yeah,
I think that's,
that's where supplementation is going in
general,
right?
It's just like we were talking about
with Diet,
how based on your genetics,
based in your blood work based and your
bio,
that's how you would choose your diet.
I mean like,
you know,
like the carnivore diet.
If you're,
if you're,
let's say like sub Saharan African or
South East Asia and you have high levels
of,
you know,
there are genes for salivary amylase,
there's one called the am.
Why one gene?
There are genes responsible for you
having a higher inflammatory response to
saturated fat or a ketogenic diet or
like there's one called the apoe gene,
apoe e three for which I have dictates
that even though I personally kind of
like a higher fat,
low carbohydrate diet,
the majority of my fats come from
Mediterranean fat sources.
You know,
a lot of olive oils like avocado oil,
a lot of fish.
And I do that because my genetics
dictate that,
you know,
my macronutrient ratio,
my diet is gonna is gonna be best suited
to that specific ratio of fats.
But you could say the same thing with
supplements.
You know,
I think with supplements,
with,
with all these different places that
will self quantify,
you know,
like wellness fx and inside track in 23
in me,
you know,
and you can,
you can take all of this data,
put it together and actually determined,
you know,
whatever my,
everybody's saying was supposed to take
2000 international units of vitamin D a
Day.
If your vitamin D levels are like 80 or
90,
then that could cause arterial
calcification if you're taking excess
vitamin D.
Um,
I had both myself and my kids tested for
our,
for our genetics,
like none of us boys in the Greenfield
family actually have the gene that
allows us to generate appreciable
amounts of vitamin D from sunlight.
So we all now supplement with vitamin D,
vitamin K,
my boys,
neither of them possess the enzyme or
the or the,
um,
I guess it is an enzyme superoxide
dismutase.
It's a gene that allows for increased
expression of this enzyme that allows
for glutathione production,
right?
So they take glutathione now,
um,
they have the one that results in a
lower than normal level of bdnf,
brain derived neurotrophic factor,
the stuff that's like miracle grow for
the brain.
So they use lion's mane extract now
before school.
So I,
I like the idea of doing a genetic test
and doing a blood test and looking at
what your ancestors would have eaten if
you happen to have,
I guess kind of like a clean enough to
interpret ancestral profile to be able
to say,
well,
here's,
you know,
I'm mostly northern European so this is
what I'm going to do well On.
You combine all that stuff.
I think,
you know,
returning to your question about the
carnivore diet,
that's the way to eat this apoe e four
is also leaves you predisposed to ct,
correct?
Yeah.
Or you have that higher risk.
Now I've got the April e three m three
four three four eight four four is the
one that's more concerning.
Yeah.
And you get a very deleterious response
in many cases to,
to fats.
You know,
it's like an inflammatory response to
fats.
Very similar,
very similar.
Like if you had familial
hypercholesterolemia,
you know,
and you get on like a a Kenogenic Diet
for example,
and your cholesterol goes up to 500 I
mean that's something that just doesn't
agree with a lot of people.
Yeah.
That's what's really important to
discuss.
Right.
Everybody's body really does respond
differently to all sorts of different
diets and yeah,
it's so difficult for people,
especially if they don't have a lot of
research in the field.
If they don't know how,
you know they're not,
they haven't read a lot about it to try
to determine what's the best diet for
them.
Yeah,
there are,
there are.
There are specific characteristics
though that regardless of macronutrient
ratios and regardless of food
composition you see over and over again
in centenarians or in people who are
living in a blue zone or people who have
the absence of a lot of,
of disease risk factors or are high risk
of mortality.
Like we see regular periods of caloric
restriction like at some point other
compressed feeding window or
intermittent fasting or like,
you know,
the Mediterranean diet,
everybody talks about goat cheese and
all of oil and fish and eggs.
But not a lot of people talk about the
religious aspect of that.
That includes certain periods of time
where you fast certain periods of time
where you don't eat meat certain days,
where where you aren't drowning all your
food in olive oil.
All right.
And so,
um,
you know,
it's,
it's uh,
in terms of other characteristics that
you see,
um,
glycaemic variability,
right?
You see very low periods of glucose
fluctuations occurring throughout the
day because of a high intake of either
fiber or legumes is a big one that you
see in the blue zones,
right?
Like high intake of things like lentils.
And Split Mung beans and a lot of these
things that get thrown under the bus now
where we're talking about lectins and
got damaged,
but ultimately returning back to what I
said earlier,
soaking and sprouting and fermentation
makes a lot of those things.
Can I pause?
You are not aware of that.
What are the issues with lectins and so
the issue with Lectins,
and this is based on a on a book that
was published I think about two years
ago called the plant paradox by doctor
Steven gundry and he talks about how
lectins are these builtin natural plant
defense mechanisms that are in primarily
plants and seeds and the skins of
certain fruits and vegetables that will
cause your digestive track to become
damaged or give you a deleterious or
inflammatory response to that food.
Kind of a similar argument as the Paleo
people make,
right?
They say,
well,
you don't,
don't eat dairy because that could have
inflammatory proteins in it that might
cause an autoimmune reaction or or
donate bread because of the gluten and
the phytic acid.
But when when you step back and you look
out a lot of,
a lot of blue zones,
a lot of longevity hotspots,
a lot of centenarians,
you don't see avoidance of these foods.
You see smart preparation of them,
right?
When you hunt,
you don't set up in a tree with a like a
dagger and your teeth like Peter Pan and
jump out of the tree on the back of a
deer and,
and you know,
just start eating the deer,
right?
Like you have to go through a pretty
long process of tracking and stalking
and hunting and,
and Phil dressing and quartering.
And even then,
you know,
there,
there's a pretty intensive cooking
process and we do things like,
you know,
like coffee rubs and things to decrease
the amount of carcinogens in the meat
when you cook it and we dry age and
you'll take the organ meats and soak
them in lemon juice or buttermilk to
remove the flavor and blah,
blah blah.
But stop,
stop,
stop.
Okay,
hold on.
I've got to do this.
Otherwise I forget.
Coffee rubs.
What does it,
how does it decrease the amount of
carcinogens?
Well Coffee Rosemary time,
a lot of these things that we use as
rubs,
one of the benefits of them as they
decrease the formation of a lot of these
carcinogenic compounds in the meat,
you know,
like the burnt,
charred components of the meat.
Anything that's an antioxidant,
right?
And you could,
you could just go on your spice cover
and start to make up rubs based on this
concept.
Anything that would be,
you know,
these sirtuin precursors that people are
talking about now for anti aging,
like blueberries and red wine and dark
chocolate and dark purple fruits and
berries,
et Cetera,
you dry those,
you powder those,
that's a great rub,
right?
Because all of a sudden you're
decreasing the carcinogenics aspects of
burnt meet or charred meat or are
heavily cooks proteins particularly.
So the idea is you want to prepare your
food in a manner that renders it
digestible and that unlocks the
nutrients.
And so when we talk about dietary
customization,
not only do you see calorie restriction
compressed feeding windows,
fasting as one element,
that regardless of the Diet that you
choose has been shown to improve health
and lifespan.
But you also see low amounts of glycemic
variability.
You see a high amount of emphasis placed
on rendering the food digestible.
Again,
no matter what it is that you're eating.
And so whether you're eating a ketogenic
diet or a carnivore diet or a high carb,
low fat,
high fat,
low carb,
what have you,
the idea is you try to choose real
recognizable food,
then you render that digestible and you
eat as many different food groups as you
can eat based on self experimentation
primarily until you land on that diet
that that works well for you.
And if you can combine that with self
qualification,
blood biomarkers,
look at your microbiome,
look at your genetics.
I mean there's no reason that that most
people shouldn't just be able to eat the
diet that works for their body,
but it's a hard thing to discover the,
the idea that you can figure out what
works best for you.
Look what feels best.
Like people start convincing themselves,
you know?
But one thing is more beneficial to the
other and that's one of the things that
people wonder about,
this whole carnivore thing.
It was like,
are they mind fucking themselves or
they're giving themselves a placebo
benefit of only eating this way and you
just go to Sean Baker's instagram every
day and you hashtag meet heels and
you're like,
yes,
meets healing me,
and you start the,
it's a church.
It's a religion.
It's a nutrition is highly religious and
dogmatic.
Well,
the carnivore diet people are the exact
opposite of the Vegan people.
They're the same but different there.
They're all just preaching that you
should only meat and meets the thing and
you know they're mocking vegans.
Vegans are mocking the cow or you know,
saying disparaging things about people
who eat meat.
It's really seminal issue is the same
thing though.
It's the fact that when you start on a
highly restrictive diet that tends to be
dogmatic to like,
I'm going to only eat meat.
I'm not going to have meat.
I'm going to only eat vegetables.
You feel pretty good,
like you feel a difference.
It's impossible not to feel a difference
once you go,
go completely myopic on your diet and
have a very limited number of food
choices.
But we know that vegans buildup deficits
and creating in taurine in,
you know,
unless the reading log and stuff like
that and Dha and epa in fatty acids and
amino acids,
long term deficits and cortisol which
affects cell membranes,
you can definitely do it right.
I mean there's dudes like you know for
can rich roll,
right?
Like great guy and he and and he's into
like the,
you know,
fermentation,
soaking and sprouting and super foods
and you know,
it's,
it's honestly kind of expensive and time
consuming to do a Vegan diet the right
way.
But you could do it.
A lot of people don't,
but if you're not careful,
you build up deficits longterm even
though you feel really good short term
as the same thing with,
with something like a carnivore diet,
like you're probably going to build up
some kind of microbiome bacterial
deficiencies unless you're eating the
intestines of ruminants or I suppose
supplementing with some kind of really
good probiotic.
Let's just fascinating because they find
these people that have been doing it for
20 years,
they,
they pull these folks out of the woods,
like,
look,
we've got this one guy,
he's been doing it for 18 years.
Look how healthy they are.
They sell,
show someone doing chin ups.
But the reality is you,
you don't really hear about that die or
you didn't really hear about that diet
until like three or four years ago.
Right.
And much more so over the last two years
probably because of me accidentally
having all these people on and talking
about it and it's,
and you know,
people like Jordan that have had,
look,
it's impossible to deny the benefits
that he's gotten.
The guy looks fantastic and just a
tremendous amount of weight.
And,
but to your point,
that is most likely because of it,
an elimination diet and whatever was
fucking with him before.
And I think,
you know,
most people that start off with a poor
die and then switch to a restricted
diet,
they're just going to be better because
they don't have the,
the stuff that's poor and they don't
have the trans fats,
they don't have all the sugar,
they don't have all the nonsense.
It's probably causing a good deal of the
information in the first place.
So by eliminating all those bad things
from their diet and then concentrating
on the one thing that they all,
the only one thing that they're eating,
you think the one thing they're eating
is causing all the benefits when it's
probably the lack of the bad things.
Exactly.
It's an,
it's a fancy elimination diet,
so,
but it's a delicious one.
It is.
Speaking of delicious,
are you hunting at all?
Yes.
What's your hunt?
Well,
I mean I'm going through the two elk
that I've given away a lot of it too.
And I shot last year,
every year I scheduled to elk hunts and,
uh,
assume I'm going to strike out.
And,
uh,
the last two years I've been very lucky
and I got to elk each year.
So it's breaking the rules of the secret
in think and grow rich,
you know,
to assume you're going to strike out.
Well I supposed to sit cross legged in
your son and manifest that shows.
Yeah,
I work hard but I assume it's a hard
thing to do to fucking it is and people
don't realize they don't and he'll,
he'll look at a clip like there's clips
of me online and the clip is like a
minute long and it seems like,
oh look,
look how easy you don't see stalking in
for hours.
You don't see the hundreds of hours of
shooting arrows.
The coaching from John Dudley,
all the reading,
archery articles and understanding what,
keeping your mindset clear in the
moment.
It's a lot of difficult to long haul.
My boys have their first hunt in three
months and we'll kind of,
we've been prepping for seven months.
They're doing bow hunt and Kona real
pig.
Oh my,
my wife,
she's going to have to sheep or is it
going to have to pay the 10?
So when you're getting him a crossbow,
no,
they're right now they're shooting a
hoyts ignite.
Um,
they're shooting at about 25 yards,
justice shooting at about 40 yards.
And how many people live in prepping?
They're about 45 now,
which is going to be enough.
That's enough.
Yeah.
But I mean there's still,
I mean there's still,
when they,
when they draw their pointing up Poland,
so they've still got a couple more
months of training to,
to really get dialed in.
Um,
but yeah,
it's,
it's difficult.
I still haven't even gotten my elk bow
hunting.
You know,
I spent my last time,
I spent six days up in the Colorado
mountain range and the,
uh,
the,
um,
what they called the Santa De Cristo
Range.
And on the last day I finally came in on
elk and it was dark and I shot and I
missed.
And that was after seven fricking days
of trying.
And you walk out your horse out
completely empty handed.
It's about 45 yards in dusk.
But you know,
I mean,
you know how it goes.
You're shaking.
It's so dark.
And,
yeah.
Um,
anyways though,
so I'm going to do a,
I'm going to do Kona,
actually gonna get you in touch with
Dudley,
cause I know,
been in touch with him.
We've talked before.
I know how you shoot.
You shoot with a finger trigger to fire.
Yeah,
I need to,
it's,
it's on my list.
But
there's those moments like that when
you,
you're hunting for six days and you just
trekking through the woods 20 miles a
day and you're exhausted and you finally
get that one moment.
There's so much weight on that moment
that it's so difficult to stay focused
entirely on the task of executing the
shot perfectly.
And there's methods.
There's a guy named Joel Turner who has,
um,
he's got a website called iron mine
hunting.
He's a,
uh,
he's a,
he's an instructor for,
um,
uh,
first responders and snipers and things
along those lines.
Iron mind,
iron mine.
Where's she live?
I think he's a Pacific northwest guy
and,
uh,
he's helped me tremendously.
His,
his methods.
It's all about keeping a,
uh,
the difference between an open loop
system in a closed loop system.
Be Able to control it and stop it and
stop the process anytime you want and
keeping yourself in that versus like a
baseball bat swing,
which is once you start swinging,
just swinging.
And the idea is to,
to maintain the present nt,
to have a mantra and he gives you a
mantra to chant and to think about it in
terms of controlling all of those
movements.
So you are in control constantly.
Well you,
you develop your own,
but the idea is to talk yourself through
it.
Don't let your excitable mind take over.
I'll just with it up a little,
he freak out and you pull the trigger
and you shoot fucking over the things
back and you don't even know what
happened.
What's your mantra?
Lost?
Um,
I,
I pull back and I say dry.
I through all the steps in my head that
I'm supposed to do,
I actually modified his and,
and went to John Dudley's.
So his,
he has his own one,
which is a drawback in aim.
Get it done,
watch it to keep it in the,
the whole idea is just keeping those
things in your head.
So you have one thing,
but what would dudley,
I go through all the different things
that he says,
like a drawback,
tip of the nose center,
the peep center,
the bubble pulled through the shot,
pull,
let the shop break.
And so I go through all those things in
my mind.
But the whole idea is that not allow the
freak out.
Cause the freak out is what causes the
target panic.
And when you have that itchy trigger
finger with the finger trigger,
you look good.
And that's,
that's,
I've done it.
I mean I've seen it,
I've done it,
I've seen it,
I've heard it.
Everybody does it.
The Arrow goes in the spot.
You know where you're yanking it and
you're pulling it.
He's not very precise and want to get it
to where it's a surprise shock.
And when it's a surprise shot,
you're just concentrating entirely on
the area that you want to hit on the
ALC.
Your form is perfect,
everything's aligned in order.
And if it's not,
you let down if it's not you let down
and tried to get your shit together.
She was trained to hunt competitions.
Helped me out quite a bit I'm sure.
But it's like a three day shoot but they
were churning around here getting
exhausted.
Well No,
not really.
Like,
like they're uh,
they do have part of it as like that,
like an obstacle course race with your
bowl.
But then part of it too is just a three
day shoot.
But like,
uh,
like a a 40 target three day shoot where
one shot might be on facing you,
but the targets behind me and you've got
a ten second time span to draw,
turn and shoot or you got to take a shot
seeded through the trees at 40 yards and
then within 20 seconds to a shot at 60
yards.
So it's a lot of hunting scenario.
We would tell you that that is going to
cause target panic,
that that whole thing of shoot now that
you should never just do that,
that you should always execute the shot
correctly.
Even he doesn't even like this fucking
game.
This thing,
this a techno hunt that we,
we've done.
He doesn't like that.
He thinks that that thing causes target
panic because you only have a brief
window and you're like go,
it's like you,
he believes that you should concentrate
entirely on the correct fundamentals and
execution of archery.
And then with time and understanding of
the situation,
the experience of hunting itself,
then when those moments present
themselves,
you're going to execute correctly.
Whereas when you have this like 10
seconds,
you've got to turn and behind your back
ready go.
He's like,
wow,
you're just,
you're just going to hit that.
You're going to hammer that trigger.
You're going to put that pin on the
target and hammer that trigger and
that's just,
you are emphasizing all the wrong things
that you could do when you're hunting.
Yeah.
Let me go to Hawaii next month and do a
sheep.
Which island?
The Big island.
It'd be Kona.
Kona.
Uh,
well I like to go down there cause you
can spear fish can,
you can double into spare fish.
So we'll do sheep and goat,
a pig,
possibly Turkey.
And then we'll have a couple days out on
the boats and that'll be actually,
uh,
kyle and Aubrey are going,
Oh yeah,
Pete,
Peter t is gonna come with us.
So while the doctor on the trip,
and then the one I'm excited about is a
dall sheep up in Alaska.
So I'm going to do that.
The Arctic National Wildlife Refuge,
that's a float hunt.
So you're floating about 40 miles down
the river up there.
You fly into a,
in a fair banks and there's a fort that
you fly in from there on a charter and
that'll be dall sheep,
Caribou and grizzlies.
That's a 10 day hunt.
And this is a bow hunt as well.
That'll be a bulb while be all pack.
Like I've got a,
yeah,
got a Smith and Wesson 44.
It's a big ass gun.
So I'll pack that and then I'll probably
have a to 72.
Um,
if I,
if I can make weight,
you hunt them or weapons or you just
avoiding them?
No,
I'm hunting dall sheep like that.
That's what I really want.
That's just an adventurous,
I'm not much of a trophy hunting guy,
but I am an adventure guy.
Like I like,
I want to go out and have an amazing
adventure wilderness adventure because
the,
the place where these things live is
some of the fucking sketchy as ground on
earth.
It's shale rock.
A lot of it you have to,
a lot of times you're wearing crampons
on your boots.
You going to extremely high altitude in
precarious situations.
These little cliff peaks long packouts
uh,
I'll have a carer will be tag and a
grizzly tag as well.
So if I like to shoot a grizzly because
it's charging you or to shoot a grizzle
cause you can,
that would actually be to harvest and
eat a grizzly.
I'm actually pretty,
you know,
I'd be like that.
I'm a cook.
Look at those dall sheep.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
So that is an adventure right there to
be able to get to those little specks on
that rock.
So hard to be floating the river,
uh,
will be fishing.
They got Arctic char up there.
Um,
few other fish.
Beautiful Fish.
Yeah.
So he gets a big fatty fish,
cold water,
it'll be about 10 to 12 days and then
I'll just fly all the meat out and fly
home.
Now grisly as a meal.
That's a thing that where people are
hearing this and they're going,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And uh,
I had Donnie Vinson on the podcast who's
a,
he's a really interesting guy,
very educated and really,
really articulate and really like,
like Rinella and a lot of ways,
does a great job of explaining what
hunting truly is about and the
conservation aspect of it.
But he's a big fan of eating bear and
he's always telling people like,
you know,
like they're all good.
Like if you prepare correctly,
all bears good.
Yeah.
Apparently the trick is to,
to get rid of the glands early on when
your field dressing.
Cause apparently that taints to meet and
that I've,
I've never feel dressed to bear,
so I don't know.
But,
um,
Steven Rinella though.
I love his cookbooks.
He's close to me.
He's up in,
um,
he's up in Bozeman.
Yeah,
I think.
Yeah.
But I've been trying to get them to come
through spokane and swing into my house
to do a podcast cause I want to actually
ask them some questions about is if you
got a new cookbook.
Yeah,
yeah.
We've connected.
We've talked a few times.
I skype,
I just got to get them to come through
spokane.
I love that guy.
Yeah.
He's the one who got me into hunting.
That's fun though.
Yeah,
it's a great cook too.
He really is.
He really understands like so many
different preparations and tries to get
people to try things like Osso Buco you
know the braise,
the shanks and yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I love that.
And how about spear fishing?
Have you gotten into into little spear
phishing and free diving?
Seen it all.
I was in Hawaii recently.
My youngest daughter is obsessed with
fishing.
She fucking loves it.
And uh,
we caught a bunch of yellow tail when we
were in Hawaii this last trip and now
she's super hooked cause you know,
she's eight and she's hanging onto this
rod and you know,
I mean I was at,
sometimes I was helping her.
Like I was holding the Rod and she was
with her two little arms crank in these
yellow tails.
And you know,
you catch a 10 pound yellow tail when
you're eight years old and the fucking,
that's a whole side thing.
Oh my God,
they're so powerful.
It's a fight.
I took my boys out for steelhead and my
boy,
my boy,
a tearing,
he almost got pulled into the water on
north fork of the clearwater big steel
head.
I mean those things are massive.
Snagged.
One's not supposed to eat them.
Right?
He's supposed to let them go.
It depends there.
There's a certain,
I forget that I forget the color,
but there's a certain style of steelhead
that you are allowed to.
He had to throw this one back.
This wasn't the one,
one of the ones that we were yelling to
eat.
Don't totally understand that.
I mean,
I kind of understand it,
but it seems to me like it is,
it's an ocean bound rainbow trout,
correct.
Yeah,
exactly.
So why can't you eat it?
I Dunno.
I Dunno man.
And there's,
there's a certain variety that you
actually can't eat.
Well,
you,
you can eat it physically,
but you're now,
I mean,
I mean legally.
Yeah,
that seems so strange to me is the idea
to protect the population because
they're in the process of breeding and
you don't want to interrupt,
but you're off.
There's a certain mortality rate that
they're accepting with catch and
release.
This is one of the reasons why I have an
issue with that and I've done catch and
release fishing.
I don't want to appear like I'm a
hypocrite because it is fun,
but there's a thing about it is like
you're just shoving a hook and the
things face and then releasing them.
That is why I like spear fishing because
you're underwater.
You're going after the exact fish that
you want.
There's no doubt in your mind I'm going
to shoot that fish and it,
you know,
you're not wondering what's going to
bite the hook,
right?
Like whether it's going to be illegal
one or an illegal one,
regardless of whether you get a fish.
It's amazing.
You're happy.
You see the coral,
you're getting it.
Yeah.
You're going down and up.
There's the,
there's all like if you're in the
fitness,
the cold thermogenesis and the breath
hold and the spleen compression and the
red blood cell production.
So I mean it's a,
it's an amazing workout.
Um,
it's just fun.
It's Zen.
Yeah.
They wouldn't let my daughter do it
though.
She's too young.
They said you have to be 13 so just a
spear fish.
Yeah.
She could probably be like shallow water
with a slang and
that's,
that's the way to do it is you want to
start off shore eight to 15 feet of
water.
You want to easy slang.
You know,
a lot of people think spear and they
think of like the big roller guns that
you gotta like put the handle against
your chest and pull back.
It's very difficult.
And then you got to dive to depths,
you know,
for,
if you're going after tonight,
you gotta be able to go like 30 plus
feet and you have a floater and it's a
very involved process.
But if you're just like in fricking
Hawaii and you've got a sling and a good
spot and some coral and some good fans
and you can just basically swim away.
Um,
I'll tie a string around my waist and
pull a knife on my belt and he can just
go out there and you know,
string four or five fish and it's an
easy day.
It's a ton of fun.
Yeah.
And it's almost like,
it's not fishing.
He'd called Spear Phishing,
but you basically hunting underwater,
hunting underwater.
They even have the,
I haven't done this yet,
but maybe you've seen these,
these underwater bows.
You can,
you can shoot a bow at the fish.
Yeah.
Had a bow.
I don't know if they called bow fishing
or what.
Have you seen this?
I've seen something like it.
Yeah,
I'm,
well,
I know there's a lot of both fish and
the people do the shooting down at
Phillip and alligator Gar in particular.
That's a big one.
They use it as well.
No,
it's supposed to be really good.
Smoked rarely.
It's a such a weird looking animal.
It's almost seems like in my mind it
almost feels like it shouldn't shoot it
cause it's a dinosaur.
Keep it alive because they really
haven't changed in millions of years.
Uh,
such a freaky look.
They're fun to prepare though.
Do a fish feed after spearfish or all
cold?
You're hungry.
Last one I did a,
we had,
we had a pair of fish down Hawaii
stuffed with avocado and mango coconut
oil paint baked in the oven with
Macadamia nut.
Like in cross the Macadamia nut parrot
fish are the ones that are eating the
coral and shitting out white sand.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Did you know that you've watched more
nature tv than I have.
That's what white sand is.
It's shit.
Really?
Yeah.
Believe it or not.
It's like these,
yeah.
These fish eat coral chew it up and shit
out the white sand.
So like a giant white sand beach like
clearwater,
Florida.
That's all fish parrot.
Fish poop makes beautiful beaches.
There you go.
There's the article.
The answer.
I wonder if it's good for your,
I wonder if it's good for your
microbiome out on bacteria.
These motherfuckers are out there just
eating rocks.
That's a lot of shit.
It's a lot.
It's a lot of pair of fish over a very
long period of time.
Millions.
You can go on a ship,
like here you go,
you can see them,
they're chewing on the coral.
They Bang it out.
They have like a beak essentially.
That's why they're calling parrot fish.
They smashed down that coral and then
all that white around them is,
they're just basically swimming around
their own shit.
That's pretty cool.
Crazy.
Very strange like that.
Yeah.
Um,
I was going to ask you something,
um,
metformin you started talking about with
David.
Yes.
David Sinclair.
He can take that.
Yes.
And the foreman maybe,
I don't know.
It seems weird because that one's a
drug.
It's like,
it's like the darling of the antiaging
industry,
you know,
it's like a nickel a pop and it's,
it's uh,
inhibits m talk to a certain extent,
but the big deal with that is his
glycaemic variability,
reduced risk of chronic disease.
But there's a lot of side effects of
that.
I want to mention that to you saying
that there's none.
No,
there's lactic acidosis and it inhibits
the,
the um,
electron transport chain in the
Mitochondria,
which is fine if you want to down
regulate metabolism live a long time and
not if you not if you're an athlete,
right?
You don't want to inhibit mitochondrial
respiration necessarily.
Um,
vitamin B 12 deficiencies like it's
derived from French [inaudible] and
physicians for for hundreds of years
been using it but in limited quantities
because it induces nausea,
right?
He'd say get gastrointestinal
disturbances.
Um,
my take on metformin cause,
cause I,
I've been looking over the past year and
to a lot of these anti aging compounds
that people are now using or talking
about using like wrap a myosin and
metformin and Nad and a lot of these
sirtuin precursors but metformin and
rapamycin actually for,
for different reasons because that's an
immune system suppressor are two that I
don't think I would ever take really.
Cause with metformin there are a variety
of natural compounds that reduce blood
glucose and improve insulin sensitivity.
In the absence of that,
like Berberine,
a curcumin,
apple cider vinegar,
sail on cinnamon bitter melon extract,
and you think all those things are
mimicking what metformin is capable of
doing?
I think so.
Um,
I'm not wearing it right now,
but usually I wear a Dexcom g six.
It's a continuous blood glucose monitor.
It actually fell off yesterday when I
was doing that exercise.
That's one of those ones who see a
diabetics where there was still sends my
blood glucose to myself on all sorts of
interesting things like,
um,
my blood glucose would spike in the
mornings like clockwork,
about 8:00 AM every morning.
And I was trying to figure out like,
why is my blood glucose going to one
2130 every single morning?
Well,
I'd have a cup of coffee in the morning
and even though I don't put cream or
sugar in my coffee,
I just drink straight up.
Black coffee.
Coffee actually causes your liver to
engage in something called
glycogenolysis.
So you actually release glucose into the
bloodstream,
which is a good thing.
And it's why you drink coffee.
You want that Cortisol release,
that glucose hit.
You know,
maybe you want the flavor and the
antioxidants too.
But I would get a blood glucose response
from coffee.
Uh,
another one that surprised me was green
beans.
Uh,
talk about legumes.
You talk about slow release
carbohydrates and it falls into that
category.
But my blood glucose would go up
whenever I'd have green beans.
So I actually got a food allergy tests
through this company called Cyrex.
They did like a really good food allergy
test that doesn't give you this big
laundry list of false positives like uh,
like uh,
there's like the Elisa and the owl cat
test.
Like the skin prick tests,
you just get like a very small number of
foods that you're actually allergic to.
Cause a lot of these other tests,
they'll show a bunch of antibodies to
food,
but it's antibodies to foods.
You're eating that food are so,
so many people would be like,
dude,
them,
I'm allergic to eggs.
I got a test on allergic to eggs and I'm
depressed because that was a big staple
in my diet.
Well,
it's only showing that you're allergic
to them cause they were a staple in your
diet because you're eating a lot of eggs
and you're winding up with a lot of
those egg proteins in your bloodstream.
But this,
this,
uh,
cyrex panel.
So basically if,
if you're eating a lot of eggs,
you actually have a lot of egg proteins
circulating in your bloodstream.
And if,
if you get a food panel,
you actually can very readily produce it
like a food allergy panel.
You produce antibodies to the egg
protein and they say that you're
allergic to the egg protein when in fact
you just have a lot of egg proteins in
your system because you've been eating a
lot of eggs.
And sometimes they'll even test the
white blood cell reaction to a raw egg,
not a cooked egg.
Right.
And so your white blood cells are going
to react more readily to a raw egg
versus cook dagger raw chicken versus
Cook Chicken.
I don't think a lot of these food
allergy panels were that accurate for
that reason.
Like,
I think they're just giving you a
laundry list of foods that you may or
may not be allergic to,
but this one is called,
it's called Cyrex.
I've,
I have no financial affiliation and
they're like that with his company but I
just think they do a good job with their
testing.
They uh,
you got to order through a physician and
I ordered this test and I was allergic
to almost nothing like barely anything
would spike for me.
Like kind of like a moderate spike for
gluten,
uh,
green beans l were off the chart off the
chart so that continuous blood glucose
monitor was actually able to tell me
that I was eating something that my
sympathetic nervous system was
responding to.
I was going to fight and flight mode,
releasing a bunch of glucose and I never
would have really known that or gotten a
clue about that unless I was wearing one
of these continuous blood glucose
monitors.
I'm not going to wear my whole life,
but I'm going to wear it.
My,
my plan is to wear for a year to just
learn a lot about the foods that I
usually eat,
what they do to my body,
what certain workouts do,
uh,
what certain supplements do.
But returning to Metformin,
I started to use a lot of these things
like bear Brene,
like curcumin.
You can do a shot of apple cider vinegar
before a meal,
take a couple of teaspoons of sale on
cinnamon in your smoothie.
And these things actually have an effect
on blood glucose that mimics what you're
trying to get when you take metformin.
That but without the side effects is
just limiting blood glucose.
Well,
like I mentioned earlier,
it does inhibit mtor low bed,
right?
So,
so you get that,
that mtor inhibition,
but you can inhibit mtor tore through
like calorie restriction and fasting
done regularly or like a compressed
feeding window should add you here
yesterday.
Yes,
there's,
Oh,
I should have had you here to talk to
Davidson.
I want to finish listening to that
interview too because he,
he's a,
he's a very smart guy,
but I just,
I'm not enamored with metformin.
Well,
he's not an APP.
Better,
more natural alternatives.
He's not an athlete.
He barely works out and a lot of side,
a little bit.
It does like a little bit of a run,
a little bit of lifting.
But you could tell he's not,
he's not a guy who's really exerting
himself rigorously.
To me,
I want the marriage of performance and
longevity.
I don't want to live a long time.
If I can't kick ass,
I feel good.
I don't want to be cold and,
and Libido lists and left home 150 like
I want to,
even if that means I'm going to live
till I'm 145 instead of 150 right.
Cause Cause I've got more muscle mass or
whatever.
Like I want to feel good.
So whenever I'm looking at a compound
like that,
I'm questioning whether or not it's,
it's the best way to go if it's going to
inhibit my actual performance.
Right.
His focus.
There's natural alternatives.
He's so focused on longevity.
Yeah.
But you could say that about a lot of
these things.
I mean like,
like cryotherapy,
chambers,
right.
I mean,
you look at the Cherokee,
native American tribe would dip their
babies and icy cold water to La were
like two years old or the uh,
there's the,
the viral video footage of the Siberian
school children.
I don't know if you've seen this one.
They,
they rush out into the snow during
recess and their underpants and they
dump cold water on themselves and run
around in the snow and then come back
inside and in Iceland based on some of
the research that was done a few decades
ago on immune system,
they let their babies sleep outside and
like subzero temperatures in strollers.
Yeah,
the Russians,
the finish,
the eastern European and they've all got
their,
their cryotherapy,
like the Baltic Sea,
you know,
you go back and forth and I go to
Finland,
they've got the men's Finnish Sauna
Society,
there's no crowd there be chambers and
it was just old school saunas.
And then you go jump in the sea and you
dry yourself off in the air that you go
back in the sauna.
So a lot of these things,
there's natural turnitin Jz and I get
flack a lot of the time cause I'm,
you know I'm one of these so called bio
hackers,
right?
I have like the,
the laser lights in my office that I
shine on my balls and I've got like the,
you know the lights that go in your ears
and I've got,
you know,
the the stem cells and Ivs and
injections.
But I always,
always want to make sure people know
that you go after the natural stuff
first.
But like natural ways to get cold,
natural ways to get hot.
If you're going to buy some expensive
pulsed electromagnetic field,
Matt,
you sure as hell better be going outside
barefoot,
right?
Like or camping or sleeping outside or
learning how to earth and ground in a
more natural way.
What is involved in earthing and
grounding?
Is there a real pickle?
There is research,
especially in terms of a reduction in
inflammation and improvement in joint
comfort.
That's a very interesting one.
And then when you take the same
frequency so that the earth naturally
emits somewhere in the range of about
three to a hundred hertz,
electromagnetic frequencies like way
lower than that.
You know,
million hertz frequencies are getting
when you're holding your cell phone up
to your ear.
But we're walking around on basically a
giant electrical matt,
like,
like there's radiation,
electromagnetic frequencies released by
Earth,
and the idea is that these fancy devices
now these mats that you could sleep on
or do therapy on,
there's a,
there's been like,
I've got one in my basement that just
packs a punch,
like who was using the race horsing
industry for a long time.
It's called a pulse centers and you lay
on that thing and it just
vibrates your whole body.
What is it?
What is,
it reduces inflammation and you think of
it like exercise for your cells.
It's opening and closing the cell
membrane.
So you're getting this blood flow.
It's called a poult centers.
It's like a giant table pulse center.
It's got different coils.
Yeah.
It's,
it's poults pulled centers is the name
of the company.
That makes sense.
Sirs or sense sense centers since the
doors,
but it's got like a attachments like
coils and pads that you can attach to
your knee or attached to like a bum
shoulder or whatever.
I'll just sit in there and and work on
my computer.
I get a massage on it every week for a
couple of hours.
So it's taking the same frequencies you
get from the earth and just magnifying
those,
just delivering them in a more
concentrated manner.
The same thing with like a like an
infrared light panel.
I don't know if you've seen these
before.
They deliver near infrared far infrared,
red light.
People will strip off their clothes and
stand in front of these things to get
more college in production or you know,
in the same way that that light that I
was talking about for your head can
enhance mitochondrial activity in neural
tissue or your,
your balls are basically little eyes.
They have photo receptors on them,
they respond to light.
You can actually increase mitochondrial
activity in the testicles,
in the Leydig cells,
in the testes to increased testosterone
or increased sperm production.
So you shoot a light in your balls and
all the ideas,
he grow more tests.
You'd go outside and you'd,
you'd sunbathing nude or you'd use one
of these lights and just standing for
it.
Like I literally,
I look,
look like an idiot at work,
but this is what I do.
I've got a light panel in front of me,
right?
I'm at a standing desk.
I worked at a standing desk.
I've got a light panel behind me and
every day for 20 minutes,
I just take my clothes off at work and I
stand sandwiched in between these light
panels and it basically blast me with
this red light.
But I also go out in the sun,
right?
Like I,
if I've got the option to do that versus
get outside in the sunlight,
I go out into the sunlight.
If I've got the option to take Berberine
and bitter melon extract instead of
Metformin,
I'd rather take the bear rain in the
bitter melon extract.
So I think he's just strips up down and
go as natural as possible.
And then once you step up to the more
advanced,
you know,
anti aging strategies or bio hacking
strategies or what have you,
you still have to look at those with a
skeptical eye and ask yourself whether
or not those are,
those are really safe or if they have
side effects that might,
you know,
in many cases limit your physical
performance.
And why do you prefer the standing desk?
Well
the whole sitting is the new smoking
thing.
I disagree with,
I think,
I think sitting is just fine.
Like it feels natural to set,
it doesn't feel like you're breaking
some rule of the human body to sit down.
Like we're sitting down right now.
It feels pretty good.
The problem was sitting is that that is
the posture most people are adopting for
eight hours per day.
Right?
The best position to be in when you're
working would be whatever position
you're not in at the moment.
Same.
You know when,
when you look at weight training,
this would not apply to hypertrophy,
which would dictate that you want to hit
a muscle over and over again using the
same angle with increasingly difficult
loads.
But for metabolic,
uh,
training,
you would want to actually throw curve
balls at your body,
right?
You had the best workout,
therefore would be the one that you're
not doing right now if your goal was,
was just to limit any type of metabolic
efficiency.
So the idea with the standing desk is,
I have that to give me yet another
position to be in during the day.
So I've got to,
I've got a true form treadmill and I had
true form modify.
It's take the dashboard off.
So I've got that in front of my standing
workstation and then I've got one of
these balance boards that I can stand on
and I've got like a stool that I can
lean against.
So I've got all these different
positions that I can be in during the
day.
And then I've got that,
that a poult centers chair in my office
that I can go and sit in.
So every 25 minutes I'll just shift to a
different position.
And My standup desk is a hand crank
stand up desk so I can crank it up and
down.
If I do want to sit at my desk and just,
it just works,
you know,
it's,
it's the idea of hacking your
environment,
of equipping your environment to be in
as many different positions as possible.
So I think that's the key to feeling
good at work,
especially when you're stuck indoors.
Do you believe in one of those,
um,
you ever seen one of those?
Uh,
it's,
uh,
you stand at your standing desk on this
variable sort of surface.
Have you seen those things where it's
like,
it's topographical,
Matt as Matt?
I'll call it
ball.
The one like in our boulder offices from
my company,
we've got the standup desks that go up.
You,
you push a button and they go up and
down.
But then what we have is just scattered
around the office.
A few of those mats,
we've got some of the,
I don't know if you've seen these
fluids,
dance things.
They're like Kinda like skateboards that
you stand on top of,
but they're not,
they're not as gnarly as a balanced
board.
So you can still focus while you're
standing on top of it.
Um,
you know,
we've got some different stools,
different chairs that will go up or
down.
So again,
even if you're in a corporate office,
I'd,
it surprises me how many people in
their,
in their corporate offices don't equip
their employees just to be able to,
to move during the day.
Yeah.
And they don't care.
And the most people aren't using
ergonomic chairs either.
Yeah.
What do you use as your,
as your main chair for Ergonomic Chair,
these chairs that we ask when we're
sitting in,
right,
what am I sitting in right now?
Pisco,
it's by a company feel like I'm not
using it to its full capacity.
What are the,
what's the purpose of the way that this
has shaped back of this?
Of Lean on it in a weird way.
Put your elbows on it if you like,
but it encourages you to have an upright
posture.
I've got this thing called a Mogo
upright.
It's a stool and I can even travel with
it cause it will compress.
It weighs about two pounds and you can
actually lean against that and get into
some different positions on that one.
So is a company that sent us something.
They have one that's basically almost
like Sana spring where you kind of have
to balance yourself out.
You have to activate more just to be one
of those at a chiropractic event once
it's,
it's like kind of makes you squeeze your
pelvis while you're in the chair.
But there's actually,
there's this dude in Finland.
Um,
he's got a company called Sally s a l.
L.
I.
He used to ride horses and he decided to
start making chairs that would get him
into the same upright position that he'd
be.
And we have riding a horse.
Yeah,
it's a saddle chair.
Yeah.
I have one of those two that revs up my
kitchen table.
That's shit.
It's still uncomfortable though.
Yeah.
Really?
It feels like your balls are sandwiched
in between these two planks.
I think the arm rods so you can spend
around if you want to sit like ac slater
style at the,
like he's what's Ac slider style chair
backwards.
Oh really?
That's AC slater in my head.
That isn't those saddle chairs.
They've,
they've got like Little Allen keys that
come with them.
And you can adjust to to your pelvic
width?
No,
it mean it fits my width.
It's just weird.
These,
the,
all those sorts of injections you've
been doing.
Just give her big ass wide pelvis.
Don't say on your chair.
That was my main chair for a long time
but saddled to it.
But then when I started using these
capisce co chairs,
it's way more comfortable.
Well if you're sitting for a long time.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
And it's just,
it's easy and I have no back pain when I
use a regular office chair and I sit for
long periods of time,
I get that center back pain from just
just poor posture,
just sitting in a curved stance or a
curved up position.
What about a treadmill desk?
We tried one of those.
See I can't do a lot on treadmill desk
production wise,
but if I'm ever let,
if somebody is interviewing me like on
skype on a podcast while I'm doing a
consult call with somebody reviewing
blood work or something like that,
I'll be walking on my treadmill.
And then I've got my microphone in front
of me and I have this program called
dragon dictation and dragon dictation
allows me to talk via like a headset and
then it'll type the words on the screen.
You see?
Is that a long time ago?
But apparently the accurate leaps and
bounds.
Yeah,
it's called training your dragon.
You get the software tells you to train
your dragon.
And so you say all these words,
you read all these paragraphs and it
learns to identify your phrasing,
the volume of your voice,
and it gets more accurate.
But it's way better than,
than the Builtin Apple,
uh,
whatever's kind of voice recognition
software.
So it works.
And I liked that because then I can just
walk,
I can,
I can talk emails,
I can talk with people.
So there's like three or four different
things that I do at work that I will
walk doring yeah,
no,
that makes sense.
That makes sense.
I I write when I'm just completely alone
and quiet,
staring at a computer because uh,
I want to spend time on each individual
word and really concentrate on what the
fuck I'm saying cause it most of the
time I'm writing standup so I need to
bounce it back and forth and to talk it
out.
It's not really the right strategy.
Yeah.
I,
I'm working on a book right now and what
I've found is for me,
I have to have a triggered environment,
like a place in my house that when I go
to that place,
that's the place where your mind says,
okay this is the riding spot for me.
It,
it's,
it's this chair in the corner of the
living
room outside my office.
As soon as I get into that thing,
it's like writing mode.
Right,
right.
And I just,
I just go Pomodoro,
I'll ride for 25 minutes,
get up,
take a five minute break,
come back.
And then that's how I do it.
Cause I just have an environment to
write in an environment and a good time,
like a specific time to write as good
too.
Like we,
you know,
hey,
now it's x amount,
you know,
it's x time.
That's,
that's when I,
right.
Yeah.
That's the idea behind 'em you'll haul
this new research they're doing on
Morning Nis eveningness uh,
chronotypes different people being night
owls versus morning larks even.
Uh,
there,
there was,
um,
it was a study I was looking at
yesterday about the response to like an
inflammatory stress or I don't remember
what the stressor was,
but like when a morning type is stressed
out in the morning,
they handle it better than when they're
stressed out in the evening and vice
versa.
And is,
it's very interesting,
this research on chronotypes.
I like the idea of just,
just being able to shift your circadian
rhythm because I travel a lot.
Like I haven't been home at 17 days.
I've got two more days on the road and
then I'll be,
I'll be home.
But when I'm going east to west or west
to east,
I use light a lot to reset my circadian
biology and called a Zeit guiders.
Right.
Like these are,
these are cues that regulate your
circadian biology.
So like eating is one you want to wait
to eat until it's actual mealtime and
whatever area of the world that you're
traveling too.
So if you arrive in whatever you know,
New York City from California,
3:00 PM you don't want to eat a bite of
food until like 7:00 PM when it's actual
dinner.
Cause that helps to regulate your
circadian rhythm.
Movement is another one.
Like you want to get outside,
go for a walk,
go for a swim,
go hit the gym.
I found that that's a big one for me.
When I went to travel,
the first thing I'd do is I check in.
I go right to the gym.
I actually sat outside,
I take off my shoes and go outside.
That's good to be good for me.
Like a rigorous workout makes all the
difference in the world in terms of like
how I actually feel if I'm training,
if I'm traveling a lot and doing shows
and I go,
I mean you don't want to,
you get to a hotel room.
We just want to lay down and relax.
You have to defy that urge.
Yeah,
I'd just go straight to the gym.
That's what I find.
If he,
if,
if he shut up the inner bitch and make
it through the first two minutes,
you're good to go.
But light is the biggie.
Light is the biggie.
So I've got like the of God,
these buds that make light that go on my
ears.
You make light into your ear and you
have photo receptors in your ears,
right?
Photo receptors all over your body.
That's why if you wear a sleep mask to
go to bed,
you still have to make the room dark
cause you got photo receptors on your
skin.
I've got the one that I was talking
about that I wear on my head.
That one was called a,
that one's called a v Lie.
The one that goes in your ears is called
a human charger.
And then I've got the one that goes in
the eyes,
that one's called a re timer,
and that one makes like this greenish
blue light that's not damaging to your
retina,
but that just blast your entire skull
with light.
So I've got light on my eyes,
light on my ears,
and a lot of my head and I'll flip those
lights on back in front of the body and
that's my home set up to get my
circadian rhythm restore.
It's what I do is if I've been back east
right,
and my body at s 4:00 AM Pacific time is
telling me it's 7:00 AM because I'm on
eastern time.
My circadian clock is on eastern time.
What I do is I wake up,
I'm not going to lay in bed for three
hours,
wait and wait until the time when I
actually do want to get up.
What I do is I wake up,
I get out of bed,
and I put on those blue light blocking
glasses.
The ones that you're supposed to wear at
night.
Right?
You know,
like the yellowish orange lenses,
but I block all light.
So I'm basically just walking around and
pretty dim setting in my house.
You know,
I'll make coffee sometimes or have some
water,
stretch out,
get some work done,
but I've got the light block the whole
time.
And then whenever the time rules around
when I actually want to start waking up,
right.
Let's say I'm like 6:00 AM I don't want
to wake up at 4:00 AM want wake up at
6:00 AM,
then I'll go down in my office and I'll
put on the,
I think the ear thing,
the head thing,
the light in front of the picture light
behind me.
I need to see if [inaudible] on an ige
story before and then you just blast
yourself like 20 minutes.
And if I do that for two or three days,
like my circadian rhythm just right back
on time,
right back on time.
And I and I fall asleep,
but I'm supposed to fall asleep.
You know,
I got to bed at like 10:00 PM I get up
about 6:00 AM and that's,
that's my cycle every day.
But I just blast myself with light when
I get,
for me,
lack of food is a good one,
you know,
make sure you use some sort of fasting
in order,
you know,
to regulate everything when you're
traveling and then exercise.
Those are the two big ones.
Yeah.
And then eating after after rigorous
training puts everything sort of back
into perspective.
How do you fast,
what's your fasting protocol?
16 hours every night.
Every single night now.
One or two nights a week I'll fuck off.
What about like longer fests during the
don't at all?
No,
haven't done that.
I started doing it.
Yeah.
I started last year to,
my protocol now is 12 to six hours of
intermittent fast every day.
Christmas,
thanksgiving,
what it like.
As soon as I stopped and I'm
competitive,
I'll set my watch.
If I finish eating at 8:00 PM I don't
eat again until 8:00 AM.
If I finish eating at midnight,
then I,
I don't eat again until you know,
gibbon midnight,
first snack.
I won't eat again until lunch at least
12:00 PM so I do that every day.
And then when I started doing,
once valter Longo came out with his
research on the longevity diet and this
whole idea of a fasting mimicking diet
inducing cellular autophagy and
enhancing longevity to the same extent
as if you were just do like a pure water
fast or stop eating.
So what you do is on a quarterly basis,
four times a year,
you were strict the normal amount of
calories that you would eat to 40% of
what you'd normally eat.
So maybe you're doing,
maybe you're just dropping one meal or
for every meal that you eat,
you're eating a little bit less and you
do this for five days on a quarterly
basis.
I started doing that last year and I
just have like this stew that I make
with split Mung beans and Basmati rice
and it's called a,
it's called kitchery.
It's an Indian Ayurvedic Cleansing Stew,
Dr Logos company L Nutra sends out these
kits called prolonged kits that are all
done for you.
But I just wanted to,
to make,
make my own stew.
That's easy for me.
I put a little coconut yogurt on it and
that's just breakfast,
lunch and dinner for me for five days in
a row.
It's almost like a,
like a seasonal cleaning.
So you do that four times a year.
And the only other thing that I do is
one or two times a month.
I try to go from Saturday dinner to
Sunday dinner without eating.
So it's almost a 24 hour fast.
And with those three things,
12 six and Ironman fast,
the quarterly five day like modified
fast and then the 24 hour fast one to
two times a month.
That's sustainable for me.
I could still perform,
I could still work out.
Um,
I think,
I think that's the way to go.
How do you feel when you do that?
24 hour fast?
Because it's a pretty good workout at
2:00 PM you get hungry the 2:00 PM in
the afternoon on Sunday.
Cause what I'll do is I'll have dinner
on Saturday and then I'll wait the whole
day and then I'll have a big Sunday
dinner.
And honestly,
it doesn't affect the workouts that much
because the magic of fasting seems to be
the compressed feeding window and not
the calorie restriction,
right.
This returns to not wanting to be hungry
and cold and libido lists if you're
going to live a long time.
So the idea is that you could fast from
Saturday dinner to Sunday dinner and
have a giant ribeye steak,
sweet potato fry,
you know,
red wine,
dark chocolate,
Halo,
top ice cream,
whatever you,
whatever you want at the end of the day
on Sunday,
eat 3,500 calories and then you're just,
you're topped off and you're ready for
the next day and you have a long period
in which you're engaged in cellular
cleanup,
cellular autophagy.
But he kind of get to have your cake and
eat it too,
cause you have a bunch of calories at
the end of that.
Are you drinking coffee?
Yeah.
So coffee's fine.
I was actually surprised you didn't ask
me when I brought in the sourdough bread
and the and the coconut macaroons and
everything,
if they would take you out of Ketosis or
break your fast,
I get that question a lot now when
people are like,
well let's put dominant people,
uh,
people want to know if the butter in
your coffee and you know,
putting a hundred calories of butter in
your coffee is going to break your fast.
Basically.
The idea is if it has calories,
it breaks your fast.
It doesn't have calories,
it doesn't break your fast zero
calories.
It's negligible.
It's like a few cholesterol molecules
and like the where they call a coffee
stall and the we all and so,
and even that,
if you use the paper filter,
you're filtering a lot of that out.
That's actually why I like French press
cause you're not filtering some of those
like brain spinning compounds.
Have you fucked around with any of that
four sigmatic mushroom coffee and yeah,
I loved that stuff.
That's actually,
that's actually before I came over here,
I had a cup of coffee and I had a packet
of that four sigmatic Mane.
Yeah,
just get it for cognition.
Yeah.
I uh,
I've been drinking there.
Those little packets.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
It's a sponsor now.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know that.
Good Fan Taro,
he lives down in Venice beach.
Smart Guy.
They,
they do place for a guy that makes
mushroom coffee.
They do a good job with their mushrooms,
so,
so yeah,
anything that has calories going to take
you out of fast.
But I'll drink a black coffee,
green tea,
both of those enhance your fatty acid
burning.
So it's actually enhancing the benefits
of a fast.
Occasionally if I'm going to do a pretty
epic workout,
the two things that I'll use in combo
are ketone esters with essential amino
acids.
You combine though it's very low number
of calories,
but that's like rocket fuel,
how much you get done at [inaudible],
about 10 grams of essential amino acids.
And then the key tones,
what I've been doing is a shot glass of
this stuff called a it ketone aid.
And then there's another company called
[inaudible] that does like it.
They all taste like ass,
but you combine those with like a little
bit of amino acids,
so you have high ketones,
hi amino acids.
But neither of those are insulinogenic
so it still keeps you in a,
in a relatively fast and state if you
want to go to a hard workout or maintain
muscle or whatever.
What about the mushrooms?
You ever fuck around with those and
they're amazing?
Yeah.
I like cordyceps.
They seem to act primarily on some of
the,
some of the pathways for oxygenation
blood cell production long.
She,
I've got all the,
I've got all the on it and stuff.
Yeah,
I'm shroom tech is good.
Um,
actually four sigmatic does,
does a quarter steps as well.
But the other one,
the uh,
the lion's Mane,
what I've been doing,
I'll do this about two times a week.
Stick a very small amount of Siliciden,
the 0.2 grams of Psilocybin,
and you'd take two packets of that
lion's mane,
the foursigmatic of lion's mane extract,
and then anything that increases blood
flow.
So it could be like beet root,
um,
any nitric oxide precursors,
you could probably try shroom tech,
um,
uh,
Niacin,
a lot of people use Niacin,
but you combine anything that increases
blood flow,
couple map packets of the lion's Mane
and then about 0.2 grams of Siliciden
and the cognitive pick me up you get
from that is profound.
I mean,
you know that siliciden increases your
sensory perception,
your ability to pick out color,
smell,
sense,
temperature,
et cetera.
But just for getting through a day of
work or even like going on a,
on a long hike or um,
uh,
I would not be surprised if our
ancestors used silicide for hunting
because you actually do get a pretty
good increase in sensory perception,
smell and sight from it and visual
acuity as well.
Yeah.
But that mix works really well where you
do the lion's mane along with the,
the width,
the silicide and extract.
It makes sense that there'd be some sort
of a symbiotic benefit to combining
those sorts of mushrooms together.
Yeah.
Well,
it's like that,
uh,
we were talking about this last time,
that doctrine of signatures,
the idea that what things look like in
nature could actually give you clues
about their benefit for the body.
And when you find lines,
man,
I don't know if you seen it in nature,
but it looks like this cluster of axons
and Dendrites,
like it looks like brain cells,
you know,
up close,
see if he could find the,
has look up like lion's Mane,
pretty bad ass looking or like there's a
lot of stuff like that.
Like,
um,
there's this place in quiet,
not I go to called quite organic
pharmacy and they just grow on his tiny
little two acre farm.
All these different superfoods like you
know,
Noni and a cow and they've got comfrey
there.
And if you dig up the root of a comfrey
plant,
there it is.
Yeah,
that's lions.
Matt is created and that night's main
great name for,
but it also looks like dendrites and
axons and neurons.
So it's very cool.
Um,
what,
uh,
Fritz and placing plan,
I have yet to actually find it in
nature,
but apparently you can find it up in
the,
up in the inland northwest where I live
anyways though.
Comfrey,
they call it nyt bone and the roots look
like knuckles and joints and human bones
and it's very good for healing up
fractures or for making like a plaster
for your joints.
A plastic Humphrey plant plaster.
Yeah.
Well what,
what that uh,
that pharmacy in Hawaii does,
they grind it into a powder and then you
reconstitute that with water and you
smear it over shoulder joint.
They could just use like a,
like a tee shirt or whatever to hold it
on there or an ace bandage.
And it actually increases the speed of
bone healing or joint healing like it.
Like it's an anti inflammatory,
they do like a,
like a muscle cream with the two made
out of the conferee.
So it's very interesting.
There's,
there's,
there's all sorts of different,
different things in nature that gives
you clues,
you know,
like the carrots and the eggs for your
eyes,
the walnuts for the brain.
I think there's something to it that
will,
how does that stuff increase your bone
healing?
Like what is it doing?
What's the mechanism?
I don't know.
It might be like some way of mineral
delivery through the skin,
something like that.
I've been blown away by CBD by using,
um,
uh,
putting,
putting cbd over muscle.
A lot of companies do.
Like,
you know what the trick with that is?
One of the guys,
one of the doctors who worked with the
Tour de France teams when showing me
this,
do you have an electrical muscle
stimulation unit?
I do.
I got like a mark pro or a complex or
what have you.
Yeah,
I got a comp.
So you put your,
your cbd oil on your magnesium or
Arnica,
your trauma,
whatever it is that you're using and you
rub that in and then you put the
electrodes on top of that and then you
put an ice pack on top of that.
So it's three things.
You've got the,
the cream or lotion,
you've got the electrodes,
and then you've got the,
the topical thing that holds it on and
the electricity drives the
anti-inflammatory deeper into the
tissue.
So it enhances the effect of like a cbd
oil or magnesium.
And the ice allows you to turn up the
electricity to a higher level without
getting uncomfortable.
So I do this at home.
I use one called a called a Marc pro and
just kind of surround the area that's
actually,
you know,
torn or,
or that's painful and I'll do a rub like
that.
But you're right.
CVD oil works amazingly for that.
Yeah.
That stuff is,
uh,
it's,
it's remarkable because it's,
you're,
you're putting it on the surface of your
skin and it's,
it,
it's weird how I can get all the way
deep into a muscle or into a joint like
a,
a lot of people use it with knee pain
and it's just,
it's remarkable how well skin is a
mouth.
Yeah.
That's why some of those personal care
products are kind of scary.
But a cbd who just don't care,
products,
personal care products,
parabens and phthalates.
And you know,
estrogen,
you know,
the Fido estrogens and endocrine
disruptors and stuff like that and them,
I mean,
you know,
they've,
they've done,
they've done studies where you know,
like,
like guys will like take a shower with
the average shampoo that's got,
you know,
like parabens and phthalates and these
things that that can be endocrine
disruptors or,
or phytoestrogen you mimic estrogen in a
man's body and they actually,
within a short period of time after
taking the shower and using these care
products,
you can actually detect this stuff in
their urine.
Like your body is actually soaking this
up and absorbing it as the very,
very interesting book.
Uh,
interviewed this guy.
My podcast is called astro generation,
about how many guys have really high
estrogen levels now from primarily their
personal care products or their
household cleaning chemicals.
So it's true.
That's tough.
Trying to turn you into a bitch.
Yeah,
it is more or less over a guy's house
and you see a bunch of sweet smell in
shampoos.
Surprise me.
Like,
like when I raced for,
for a team Timex,
we used to train out at the,
the giant stadium in New Jersey and I go
in the locker room there and it's just
like this.
You'd think that the,
the peak of performance and professional
sports would have started looking into
by this point,
how could you keep testosterone is high
as possible on a male athletes body.
Right?
But you walk into the bathroom and it's
just like every end of can disrupt or
known to man.
Just like lined up in a pretty shiny row
there on the shelf in front of the
meeting of the shaving cream and the
shampoos and the spray deodorant.
Just like,
I mean any,
I did not all shaving cream,
but if it's,
if it's something that has those kinds
of chemicals in it,
absolutely.
Have you ever used Dr Carver's shave
butter and that sounds familiar.
It's a,
it's a,
uh,
dollar shave club,
a product.
It's the most fun,
incredible shaving cream of all time.
Like you'll regular shaving cream.
You will,
you won't,
you just won't use it after you try that
stuff.
I think I've tried that because he's s
this probably happens to you.
You get lots of lots of personal care
products since your studio.
I'm home.
Yeah,
but that stuff blows me away.
It's like a butter.
I mean it was called the Dr Carver's.
Yeah.
Huh.
Interesting.
I'll get them sent us off to try to try
and be blown away by.
I don't have to shave that much,
so don't have him send very much.
You don't cheat.
You don't grow a lot of [inaudible]
girl.
A lot of facial hair.
No.
No,
but yeah,
these,
these uh,
all your experimenting you'd think and
think something would have sprouted,
but you'd think it'd be kind of weird.
Like it just be like one right side
patch of the chin and it's like a hair.
But there is a mole attached to the
hair.
Do you ever wonder,
let's go.
It's going to yourself.
Stem cells bleeding out the end.
Sit in bed occasionally.
Like there's some of this stuff on stem
cells that admittedly are a little bit
of like adventure into human
experimentation without robust evidence
of safety.
How about the one where you shot onto
your deck?
That's,
that's a good example.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
I'm,
I'm kind of shifting my whole philosophy
on stem cells to kind of go after stuff
from my own body as much as possible.
Being autologous,
you know,
you're on like that one I did in New
York City,
he says it's not somebody else's blog,
it's just my own stuff.
Or you know,
in some cases you could argue that
placental or umbilical or amniotic cells
are so young and so plurry potent,
you know,
and if they don't have the,
the,
uh,
the DNA in the nucleus,
which apparently they can,
they can kill off somehow,
which is how they make exosomes.
Like you're not getting somebody else's
DNA,
you know,
it's,
it's just something your body would've
made anyways and recognize itself.
So,
yeah,
some sometimes though,
um,
sometimes though I probably have taken
it too far with a few of those things,
but,
uh,
but the cbd that you were talking about,
I'm a huge fan of,
I take cbd before bed every night.
Um,
[inaudible] a lot of it,
when you look at the studies on cbd for
anxiety and for sleep,
most of them are pushing 100 and up to
900 milligrams,
which is nuts.
When you look at the actual serving size
of the average cbd tincture or a capsule
or pill,
it's like 10 now,
so you got to take a lot of it.
But I sleep like a baby.
Like last night I got the ring that I do
my sleep squad.
I slept eight and a half hours last
night and I take a hundred milligrams of
CBD.
I take a little bit of Melatonin and I'm
just out.
But you got to take a lot of,
and you wake up kind of groggy when you
do read it.
But if you're used to that and you know,
like you get up,
shake it off,
10 minutes later you're good to go.
What's the radio was coming?
Well,
probably just overstimulation of the
endocannabinoid system.
Here's like super relaxed,
which I want to be when I sleep.
Right,
of course.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
it works.
What about regular marijuana?
Does that affect your,
your sleep?
Do you find it beneficial or no?
So cbd can enhance your deep sleep
cycles,
which is,
which is when a good majority of your
neuronal repair and recovery occurs.
THC allows you to sleep and it actually
decreases sleep latency,
how long it takes you to fall asleep.
But it does reduce the amount of time
you spend in deep sleep,
right?
So if you're,
if you're one of those people whose mind
races who's hyper charged up when it,
you know,
and you got to get to sleep at night,
use thc light,
like you know,
hit a vape pen or whatever,
but know that you might miss out on some
of the things you want during deep
sleep,
memory consolidation,
neuronal repair and recovery.
You know,
nervous system repair,
but it's still pretty decent sleep and
you're not getting as much of a
reduction in deep sleep as you would get
if you were to be taking like Ambien or
valium or something that's literally
just like a sledge hammer for your
frontal cortex that knocks you out.
But you almost get no deep sleep.
So if you do this,
if you were to get like a sleep tracker
and test your deep sleep levels,
you would find that with cbd you don't
fall asleep as fast,
but you get higher deep sleep levels and
then with thc you can fall asleep
faster,
but your deep sleep isn't quite as high.
When you consider that CBD can
counteract a lot of effects that thc,
then that means that what you could try
is take thc to lie to fall asleep
faster,
but then pile a whole bunch of cbd on
top of that.
And I've done that before too,
were just take a hit on a vape pen and
then take a bunch of cbd and you shoot
for the best of both worlds.
Folks that are taking ambient,
I mean that is,
I mean especially people that are doing
it virtually every night,
that has got to have a profound effect
on your brain's ability to recover.
I think there are a lot of people
shorting themselves on the life who are
taking ambien or valium.
I mean,
I,
I think to start with sleep,
you need to rely on your body's own
internal chemistry and that would be
breath work.
Like I think everybody before they start
taking whatever phosphatidyl,
searing and adaptogenic herbs and all
this shit for cortisol and before they
start taking valium or Ambien or
anything else for sleep,
you should learn how to control your
physiology with your breath.
I think that's the most powerful way to
do it.
I mean,
you Prawna your shock or whatever you
want to call it,
like being able to do things like breath
work,
box breathing,
alternate nostril breathing,
uh,
even even holotropic breathing,
like you can go some very interesting
places in terms of dmt production by the
pineal gland,
by just doing holotropic breathwork.
Like there's,
there's a lot of very interesting things
that you can do with your breath.
But I think that for getting to sleep or
for decreasing stress,
you start with the breath and then you
start to introduce some of these other
molecules.
But ambien valium like in the era of
like readily available cvd and you know,
all the other sleep compounds that we
have available,
like Valerian and passion flower and
mill and you know,
all of those are what are called gamma
aminobutyric acid or Gaba precursors.
They produce inhibitory
neurotransmitters.
I God,
I don't understand why people are still
taking ambien and valium because they're
idiots.
Yeah.
There's this addicted to it or they just
want a pill.
I mean,
that's essentially what it is.
They want some fat in their box and they
want ambien and invalid.
I don't know if it's the same folks,
but many times it is.
I think it's our president.
I think our president takes that shit.
He,
I think he's sleeping with ambien.
I think a lot of politicians do that.
Yeah.
Well the can't sleep otherwise they're
fucking ruining the world.
I,
um,
I've found that if my brain is racing,
just completely concentrating on
breathing in and breathing out and
concentrating on just the breath itself,
like really being cognizant of it and
slow,
deliberate breaths in and out and in.
And now by doing that over long periods
of time,
I've,
I've found that I can,
I can pretty much calmed myself out.
But that takes focus.
A lot of people are not willing to learn
how to do that because they want the
fast track out there.
She'll take a drug and pass out.
That is the thing,
right?
They just want a pill.
Yeah.
It's very unfortunate that those things
exist in that,
that that sort of thinking is,
you know,
it's reinforced.
Yeah.
It's encouraged.
In fact,
you know,
all these ads and all these doctors and
different people,
well if you have a hard time sleeping,
I'll just write your prescription.
And then next thing you know,
I mean you look at the animal world,
like they self medicate,
they'll use clay for parasites and you
know,
dogs leak grasp who stomach issues and
you know,
that I guess birds now are putting like
nicotine and cigarettes and their nests.
Cause there's some kind of benefit to
that.
And you see animals self-medicating,
you see our ancestors using everything
from,
you know,
cannabis to Ceylon cinnamon to,
all sorts of different derivatives.
For thousands of years.
So it's not like supplementation or self
medication or the or the whole creation
of pharmaceuticals is something that's
unnatural or not acceptable human
activity.
But once you start to use it as a
crutch,
I think that's where you run into issues
like once,
once you deny the human body's ability
to be able to heal itself or to be able
to decrease stress on its own,
you begin to rely on these exogenous
chemicals.
I think that's where you start playing
with fire.
I just wonder what's happening to
people's minds over longterm use of this
stuff where you're not going into these
deep sleep cycles and you're using it
every night because essentially once you
get hooked on it,
a lot of people have a really hard time
sleeping without it.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean they're shorting themselves.
Right,
right.
I wonder what studies in the emory,
it's learning like that.
That's where a lot of that type of stuff
happens.
I mean it's the same thing with,
with um,
uh,
what's it called,
the glymphatic drainage,
like this,
this new drainage system for the brain
that they've just discovered in recent
years.
This idea that you actually detoxify the
brain during the sleep cycles and it's
even enhanced when you sleep on your
side.
They even looked at sleeping positions
in this thing called glymphatic
drainage.
And when you're not going through proper
sleep cycles or you're constantly
waking,
cause you're on your back and you have a
lot of people have sleep apnea where
you'll look at their sleep charts and
they'll frequently wake during the night
or the,
you'll see periods where they just get
ripped out of deep sleep.
Yeah.
You wake up and you don't have memory
consolidation or you don't have the type
of neuronal repair and recovery that
you'd want or you know,
you,
you can even short yourself on muscle
repair,
you know,
and,
and there's,
there's probably a lot that we don't
know about just dreaming and its ability
to be able to do things like help form
memories or,
or make learning or experiences more
deeply rooted.
But yeah,
I mean it's,
it's,
I think sleep architecture is something
that just gets super fucked up in a
modern post industrial era.
We've got access to pharmaceuticals and
just take a sledgehammer to our heads.
Yeah,
no question about it.
And it's also,
there's been a lot of work done on
actually going to sleep with a problem.
It's whole idea of sleep on it.
Like there's,
there's actually something real to that
that there are some,
there's some cognitive balancing that's
going on while you're sleeping,
while your mind is actually going over
whatever issues you might have and
trying to come up with a problem during
sleep time during your subconscious,
you don't want to know how many times
now I,
and I'm learning this as I get older,
that you delay a decision or you delay
replying to an email or delay responding
to a text message or what have you until
you've gotten a full night of sleep on
it and the clarity that you get after
that.
I mean he just basically think about it
a little bit before you fall asleep and
then he'd go to sleep and you wake up
with such a better answer.
The same thing with the lock on it,
like walk on it is another thing.
We know you,
you make more nerve growth factor and
more brain derived neurotrophic factor
when you walk while you're learning.
I recently gave a Tedx talk and I just,
I,
I made the whole Tedx talk and I learned
the whole thing while I was walking up
on the farm road back behind my house.
I just walk them through the forest,
pop out in the sunshine,
walk up and down that road and just
listened to my ted talk on my earbuds
and give my talk and it's just,
it's a,
it's amazing for the brain,
but yeah,
I agree.
Dwelling on something before you go to
sleep.
It does the trick.
I always,
if I do that,
I always have a response the next day.
That's kinder,
less emotional,
more understanding,
friendlier,
reciprocating,
any,
any sort of good vibes.
It's,
it's,
it's really interesting.
It's really,
it really interesting how there is some
sort of a wisdom that's imparted on you
while you're sleeping.
There is an,
and now what I do is I'll think about
what it is,
but I am a big fan of fiction.
Before he fall asleep.
He just let you escape to a whole
different world.
I took my kids on this giant tour of New
York City,
like we went,
we went to Chelsea market and the high
line park and the empire state building
and Ellis Island.
We just did it all.
But we went across the street from
Central Park to the New York historical
society where they had a Harry Potter
exhibit.
And we walked in there.
I've just always been resistant to the
Harry Potter phase late and just,
I've never read the books and they're
watching the movies.
Uh,
but my kids really wanted to go.
So I took him and when I walked through
there and saw all the research,
the deep research that that j k Rowling
did on Alchemy and herbology and uh,
and the history of magic and you know,
wizardry in,
and she,
she actually took a deep dive in all
this stuff.
She preplanned out all seven of those
books before she even wrote the first
one.
And all of her original manuscripts were
in there and letters back and forth to
the editor and to the publisher.
I walked out the other end of,
of that exhibit.
It took us about two hours to get
through,
you know,
just looking at everything,
thumbing through everything.
And I was just like a die hard Harry
Potter fan.
Where is this?
This was that.
It was one of those things that was at
the New York historical society.
But you know,
a lot of these,
they'll do an exhibit and they will kind
of go in and out during the year.
So I doubt it's still going right now.
Cause this was like three months ago.
And,
uh,
you know,
we walked out and I'm,
my kids are like,
Dad,
this is the griffendor wand and this is
the,
the slitter or Dumbledore Swan and the
griffendor sweater and the,
the slither and sweater.
And I just started buying them all the
sweaters and the wands and now I'm
reading the book.
So I'm,
I'm halfway through goblet of fire right
now and I'm actually digging it like 10
year old red all.
Yeah.
She read a home.
Isn't the course of a year if you've
gone to the universal ride?
No,
but they have a brochure for that down
at the Hilton where I'm staying.
It's amazing.
And the Harry Potter world ride and it's
incredible.
Reedy Rod,
where you're on a rollercoaster,
but it's not three d but it's,
you know,
augmented or that'll be next for me.
I'm a fan.
I'll go by myself,
scream my hands up in the air.
He'll love it.
Yeah,
it's really good.
The whole Harry Potter world is really
good.
It's [inaudible] butter beer though.
It'll give you diabetes.
Well,
my,
one of my boys made butter beer first
class classmates because they've got
like a,
a,
they helped mom with all this stuff.
They've got like a cooking podcasts and
they do a,
their last episode was marshmallows.
They made marshmallows but there's like
a cup's worth of bone broth and every
marshmallow and it's like this healthy
like glycine and fuse marshmallow that
they made a dark chocolate fondue with
coconut flakes,
that much bone broth in a marshmallow.
What does it feel?
I don't have the recipe but it tastes
like I'm,
I'm usually not much of a sneaks snacks
into bed kind of guy.
But I was like taking marshmallows to
bed,
eating marshmallows,
reading Harry Potter.
How much sugar is not a lot.
Not a lot.
No,
they,
they're doing a good job with their
podcasts.
Like they're doing a lot of like,
like black strap,
molasses,
Stevia,
raw honey and they're doing like,
uh,
um,
what else did they make?
They made like a,
like a uh,
a gluten free baked donut with a cream
cheese ginger frosting and counted was
on top that just like you dip it in
coffee and it tastes like a real donut.
Good low.
They are turning into little little
chefs.
They didn't make me hungry.
Guess what?
What's the benefit of grass fed beef
over regular be fine.
I know there is a benefit but I don't,
I don't,
I never can recall correctly.
It's something to do with the most
central fatty acid ratios.
Yeah.
Cause grain you're going to,
you're going to have more of the omega
six fatty acids which have been unfairly
vilified,
meaning that a lot of people are just
like don't eat any Omega sixes.
Don't have any arachidonic acid.
Like don't,
don't overdo your seed,
your nuts,
your nut.
Kind of like the,
the orthorexic health world as a whole.
You know like when you read nutrition
magazines and stuff,
they're like do your Omega threes but be
careful.
Americans have a 20 to one omega six to
Omega three ratio.
But the problem is that a mega six is
that's a lot of those are derived from
what are called parent essential oils.
And your cell membranes need a certain
amount of omega six fatty acids from
seeds and nuts and plants and even to a
certain extent,
grains.
And when you have an excess of Omega
threes and not enough,
we'll mega six is because you're going
so far into the fish oil category than
it actually damages a component of your,
your mitochondria membrane called Cardio
Lipid.
You actually make less of that and so
interfere with normal sylar activity.
What seeds are most beneficial?
Uh,
uh,
I,
I would imagine the most nutrient dense
ones,
so specific weitzman's Macadamia.
I mean,
what I is like almonds,
macadamia nuts,
prezoned nuts.
I just don't eat the quasi nuts like
peanuts,
which are,
you know,
they're not as high in nutrient density.
They're more of a legume than a nut.
Um,
I,
a lot of my nuts either raw or lightly
roasted.
You always look at the label and make
sure they didn't put a lot of vegetable
oil and canola oil in them a little.
You know,
I'm,
I'm a fan of nuts in,
in modern [inaudible] my nuts.
Like you're nuts if you were going to
have to shell them,
right?
Like if you've ever had to shell a
walnut,
you're not going to eat 30 walnuts cause
that'd be exhausting.
Right?
Yeah.
I like Shell.
It's annoying as hell but keeps you from
eating too many of them.
I buy them shelled and I eat fistfuls of
them.
Yeah.
Like last night I like a half a bag.
Yeah,
it pistachios are great for your
microbiome to,
yeah.
I actually had a couple of research
studies on that last year that showed an
improvement in the diversity of the
bacteria in your gut with pistachios.
That's one of the nuts as good for your
bob,
probably because of the fiber content in
pistachios,
but grass fed versus grain fed is
primarily the omega three fatty acids
may have less of the arachidonic acid,
less of the potentially inflammatory
omega six fatty acids.
There's probably part of it being that
grass fed grass finished beef is
generally raised on a farm that's using
less herbicides,
less pesticides,
raising their meat and a more
sustainable fashion.
You know,
giving it less hormones,
getting less antibiotics.
That's painting with a broad brush.
But generally grass fed,
there's more to it than just the fatty
acid composition.
It's just a better meat overall.
In my,
well better health wise grain fed beef,
I will not lie like you can,
you can have a pretty damn tasty fatty
cut of grain fed beef.
I certainly can,
but I honestly prefer the taste of grass
fed.
I liked the dense or meet the darker
meat.
I liked it better.
It's just,
to me it just,
it,
it just tastes healthier.
I just,
I crave it more,
you know?
And when I go back and forth between the
two of them,
when I eat grain fed,
it feels like like a lazy cow.
Like it's mushy and Scott like it's
good,
it's delicious.
Don't get me wrong.
But there's a difference.
It's kind of funny cause I've gone over
to Dubai a few times and tall light
fitness conferences over there and they
advertise grain fed like they want
everybody to like when you go to the
rest of it was like this beef is the
finest grain fed beef fat on a grain
pretty widely recognized as the greatest
steakhouse in the world.
That place is all crazy.
That trip,
I acid,
I didn't like my steak at how fucking
dare you.
I know I'm gonna get,
I'm going to get
some rude Brooklyn waiter's going to
take me out.
But uh,
I didn't like,
it was just something about like,
the meat just tastes it,
it tasted like it was drenched in
vegetable oil.
Like something about it just didn't
taste right and maybe I had a poor Peter
Luger's experience that doesn't even
make sense.
I did not enjoy it that much.
Food.
I ate there and afterwards I'm like,
I don't think it gets better.
I don't think,
I don't think food gets better.
Yeah.
How dare you.
Or New York does have a lot of good
restaurants,
so y'all,
they do.
My Buddy David Bouley,
he's a chef over there and he has this
wonderful restaurant where he brings
like doctors and nutritionists in and
they teach you about certain aspects of
the food that you're eating.
Like I did one there on longevity and I
taught about like having bitters before
your meal to reduce your,
your glucose and your insulin response
to the meal and the use of like,
like sweet breads for your thymus gland
to increase the activity of your immune
system to uh,
you know,
like a lot of these polyphenols and
antioxidants from the purples and the
Greens and the blues to uh,
there were these things called
uncoupling proteins that actually get
activated with,
with cryotherapy and cold water
immersion,
but that also are something that get
activated with the consumption of a,
it's,
it's like a sea urchin is basically,
it's like a sea urchin foam that they
did at this dinner.
But basically what he does is he'll
partner with the physician or the,
or the nutritionist or whatever.
I make this amazing like four hour,
you know,
five star meal that's designed to
enhance the health effects and whatever
it is that you just learned about.
And I was actually in New York when I
did that blood procedure a couple of
weeks ago.
I,
I dropped in there again and eight and
that's when my favorite places to go to
a steakhouse in New York City.
He's that guy who fucking sprinkles of
salt.
What the Hell's his name?
Salt Bay.
He's got a place in New York.
So you know this guy,
you know know that that fucking,
that meme,
I don't know.
The guy's got the saw off,
throw it on the meat.
No,
you're too busy doing actual work.
But I like salt.
I like,
I like good salt.
As a matter of fact,
you know what the very best salt that
you can get as what this is based on.
I was with a group of doctors a couple
of months ago in park city and this guy,
one of the guys who was there was like a
water and assault expert and he did
what's called a mass spectrometry
analysis of all these popular salt like
Himalayan Sea salt and Black Kona salt
and as tech salt and Mexican salt and
you know all these different salts and
analyze them for their,
their mineral content because you want
high mineral content but their metal
content,
right?
Like we know that iron,
especially in guys now we're finding out
it's not that great.
It's,
it's oxidated.
It can cause damage associated with
inflammation.
We know that metals and and
microplastics and all these kinds of
things are winding up in the food
supply.
The top of the list in terms of
cleanliness and it's Celtic salt,
it helped it.
Celtic salt,
you know blue bag.
It's kind of like a grey salt and it's
gray because they don't like bleach it,
but it's still clean.
It's not like pink and reddish cause it
doesn't have a lot of irons.
Heard of Celtic Celtic's yeah.
That's amazing.
It's flavorful.
It's big.
It's big chunk.
So we're 12 meet rub.
I carry.
So yeah,
I mean you can buy it anywhere.
Yeah.
And that,
that stuff is about the healthiest salt
you can get.
Okay.
According less dude.
Yeah.
I like it.
I started,
you know,
I always travel with some kind of salt.
My wife gets pissed because,
you know,
she'll make these amazing meals and the
first thing I do is I just pull out the
salt does cover everything in Salt,
but I think it's because I excrete a lot
of salt when I raced for uh,
for,
for uh,
for timex actually they brought in a
bunch of physiologists to,
to test our sweat sodium or sweat sodium
analysis,
meaning that they,
they measure how much sodium you excrete
for any given volume of sweat and this
kind of returns,
that whole genetic thing.
Like when you look at people of a
northern European ancestry who would
have come from a population that did a
lot of fermenting,
a lot of curing,
a lot of pickling,
we would develop some pretty robust
sodium excretion mechanisms,
right?
Because we're,
we're preserving our food with salt.
You don't want all that salt to build up
in the body because theoretically you
could increase blood pressure,
he could cause some damage if you have
too much salt.
And when you look at other folks who
didn't,
you know,
people who would for example sweat a lot
and live in a hot environment,
you know like,
like whatever South Africa are very hot
region of the Philippines or whatever.
They would have some pretty robust salt
conservation mechanisms to be able to
hold on to sodium and hold on to salt
because you're sweating more.
While my sweat sodium analysis revealed
that I lose like two and a half times
more salt in my sweat than the average
person.
So I think that dictates to a certain
extent my almost my craving for salt.
When I was racing ironman triathlon,
I would lay awake at night and I could
feel my blood pounding in my ears after
a day of training.
And I started using salt heavily.
And one of the first things that
happens,
because salt regulates aldosterone,
which is one of the compounds that
regulates your blood pressure.
All of that went away.
Like I could fall asleep at night.
You know,
when you lay your head down on your
pillow and I couldn't hear the blood
pounding in my ears.
So for about four years,
I've just,
I've been salt on everything.
It's a ton of it.
I'm so,
I got to wrap this up,
unfortunately.
That was awesome though.
You're the best dude.
Thank you so much.
It's always good to talk to your,
I don't know how the fuck you retain all
this information,
but I'm glad
you do.
Thanks man.
Thanks for having me.
My pleasure.
I'll just give everybody your instagram,
your stub.
Google Ben Greenfield on.
There you go.
All right.
Thank you brother.
I appreciate it.
Thanks,
ma'am.